all right um it's now after uh 10: and
I'm going to call the uh uh meeting of
the uh house Judiciary Committee to
order uh and we'll begin uh by uh uh
stand I ask you to stand please for the
leave
and before we begin ladies and gentlemen
I would like to uh recognize and welcome
a new member of our committee
representative Ben Ming of hollace uh
welcome thank you
representative all right um then I'm
going to commence the hearing on
uh I'm sorry on
uh uh Constitutional Amendment
concurrent resolution 23 relative to uh
the right to abortion and um I believe
we have uh a man uh uh tol uh the
sponsor Prime sponsor of the bill uh
first good morning honorable committee
members thank you for being here today I
am here with a critical effort that
transcends party lines and speaks to the
fundamental rights of every individual
in New
Hampshire I am the prime sponsor of
ca23 which explicitly protects abortion
up to 24 weeks and after allows doctors
to work with their patients to make
these complicated decisions this
Constitutional Amendment takes abortion
out of our hands as politicians and puts
it where it belongs with doctors and
with
patients as many of you are aware the
landscape of Reproductive Rights in
America shifted dramatically since the
Supreme Court overturned Row versus Wade
in June of
20122 in the wake of this court decision
all federal protections for abort
abortion have been eliminated and the
responsibility has now fallen to the
states to protect abortion rights and
over the past 18 months we have
witnessed an alarming Trend Across the
Nation with already more than 20 States
having enacted abortion
bans while abortion is currently safe
and legal in New Hampshire to dat there
is no right to abortion and New
Hampshire lawmakers have refused to take
action to make abortion an explicit
right that means that we have zero state
or federal Protections in place that
Safeguard the right to an abortion so
even though abortion is currently legal
until 24 weeks in New Hampshire we are
just one election away from abortion
rights being further restricted or even
eliminated we want to change that today
we are joining with our colleagues from
across the aisle to propose a
constitutional amendment that will when
passed enshrine protections for safe
legal abortion in the New Hampshire
Constitution last year I introduced cacr
protecting reproductive freedom in the
past year I've worked hard with some of
the nation's leading civil liberties and
reproductive rights attorneys from
nonpartisan organizations to draft a
bill that is specific to the needs of
New Hampshire and took into
consideration the feedback I received
from this
committee we believe that everyone
deserves the right and ability to make
their own decisions about pregnancy in
consultation with their trusted health
care provider this constitutional
amendment protects abortion and puts the
decision in the hands of patients and
health care providers not
politicians I stand here today as one of
the millions of people who have received
abortion care I had my abortion as a
teenager and it has allowed me to lead
the life I have lived go to college to
graduate school to receive an me to
teach middle and high school to be a
state representative and to have my
children when I was
ready I'm about to have my third child
and I'm grateful to have my children
when I'm in a place where I can meet
their physical and emotional needs
we know that a super majority of granite
Staters support abortion rights and they
do not believe that the government
should interfere in a woman's ability to
make her own personal decisions New
Hampshire has a long bipartisan history
of supporting privacy when it comes to
personal medical decisions this
bipartisan proposal represents these
Granite State values and is sponsored
and supported by Republicans
Democrats and
independents regardless of your personal
beliefs on abortion I would encourage
you to vote for this cacr so that the
people of New Hampshire can weigh in on
this ballot measure and we no longer
need to debate this issue annually let's
let the granite Staters decide thank you
so much for your time thank you
questions from members of the committee
yes representative
Kat thank you chair but thank you for
taking my question was it your intention
to have abortion be legal after 24 weeks
through birth for reasons Beyond life of
the mother and fatal fenal anomalies as
is in Statue now or would you be
supportive of an amendment to be in
alignment with the current statute thank
you for the question abortion up until
birth doesn't happen it's an
inflammatory statement and we have lots
of providers here to testify today on
that complicated topic and to set the
record straight I trust providers in New
Hampshire and I trust that the voters
trust providers and patients and that's
what this cacr is all about thank you
follow yes follow
up so then you would be okay with
amending to state that it would be legal
per the current
statute we don't so I do not believe
that this needs to be amended I believe
it is perfectly written as is by the
states by the Nations not just the
states the nation's leading civil
liberties and civil rights attorneys to
protect the patient provider
relationship and I trust doctors and I
believe that if we give this to the
voters which we should that they do too
thank you so much other questions for
this wi yes representative
Perez thank you for taking my question
weeks we
believe
that the
current
statue it doesn't protect not that we
believe we know we are the only state in
New England that does not have any
protections either in law or the
Constitution to protect abortion rights
and so it is really necessary we don't
want to go backwards we want to move
forward and we want to make it so
doctors and their patients can make
these decisions throughout pregnancy
free from politicians as most New
Hampshire constituents do thank you so
weeks because the current statue right
now restricts
and penalizes doctors at that juncture
and the majority of granite Staters are
alarmed by that Trend and they trust
Physicians they trust physicians in
their patients and we should trust them
by putting this as a ballot measure and
there are Physicians here today who will
speak to that in Greater detail about
why this decision should be left with
them and their patients in order to
serve them to the best of their ability
thank you for the question other
questions for this witness yes
representative
stapl thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question on the bill page
one
line
19 says after 24 weeks the state may not
prohibit an abortion that in the
professional Judgment of an attending
physician
is
necessary The Physician shall apply the
applicable standard of care in making a
professional
judgment but the are are there not some
other things missing like the presence
of a medical
emergency um the explanation of a reason
for that physician
decision or even for a a second opinion
by another
physician are any of those things
reasonable to include in the in the
absence of what we have
here we believe that this amendment is
perfectly written and that it represents
what Granite Staters have called on us
to do which is to trust doctors to make
these decisions in consultation with
their patients and it does not need to
be amended in any way shape or form
thank you for the
question yes follow up represent
Stapleton and then representative Devon
thank you what I was what I was getting
at
um there's no differentiation between an
elective abortion and one for medical or
emergency
reasons um we're absent of type and
print here on this bill to
explain it's all up to one person one
physician
not even to the mother or the father or
the
family we believe that this actually
does keep the sanctity of the patient
provider relationship at the Forefront
of this discussion and that's exactly
where it should be not with legislators
and again we have many providers here
today who can speak to that in Greater
detail about why that is such an
essential component of this C ACR thank
you representative Devon well set all
right any other questions from any other
so I guess I have two questions um and I
should say uh this my first question was
brought to my attention by another
representative I I thought very
appropriately um it says in the First on
line three every individual has a
fundamental right to abortion if you
leave the wording that way does that
mean that the father has a fundamental
right to demand de either demand or
object to an abortion for the
mother this is actually very clearly
written for the patient so for the
person whose body it belongs to um it's
your body your choice and consultation
with your provider thank you so you you
think that that language is clear that
it is only the person who is pregnant
that can it is the pregnant person and
then after 24 weeks in consultation with
their provider okay although it doesn't
say the pregnant person it says every
individual so again if the you don't
think that that at least raises a
question that somebody could make the
argument that it didn't I believe that
the attorneys that wrote this are
correct in that it is about the patient
and making these decisions in
consultation with their providers and
we'll have many expert Witnesses
today reiterating that point okay thank
you the next question I have is this the
next
line says the state cannot prohibit
restrict delay or penalize the right uh
prior to 24 weeks unless it is justified
by a compelling State interest achieved
by the least restrictive means and I
guess my question
is that last part is not in current law
so so is if we were if the voters were
to pass this amendment would they
actually be placing more restrictions on
abortion than exist now under current
law because the current law doesn't say
you can prohibit abortion before 2 24
weeks if there's a compelling State
interest as I understand the current law
it says prior to 24 weeks if a woman
wants to have an abortion she has the
abortion and nobody has a right to ask
you know anything about is there a
compelling reason for this or not
actually under the current law abortion
is not proactively protected as a right
and that's exactly what this does and we
have expert Witnesses today who can
speak to that in Greater detail but
again this was written by some of the
leading civil rights and civil liberties
attorneys in the nation explicitly with
the goal of protecting abortion rights
and the sanctity of the patient provider
relationship and the majority a super
majority of granite skaters support it
and when you go and I hope you do and
you look at the signin for
today the people have spoken that they
want you to
support this
cacr and I hope you give them
opportunity to do that and I'll be
handing out again it's not one party
it's bipartisan this is co-sponsored in
a bipartisan way and I'm going to be
handing out in addition to Senator
Fenton gave me testimony and so did
Senator Cindy Rosenwald but John winter
who
is was the Republican nominee for
Walpole and a former Vice chair of the
Walpole Republicans has given me his
testimony too so we know in our state
that across party lines constituents are
asking for this and so we should come
together and give the voters the
opportunity to weigh in and decide for
themselves thank you so much for the
question any other questions all right
see seeing none thank you very much um
next I'm going to call on representative
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for hearing uh some information I wanted
to pass on on this cacr 23 could I just
ask you to get a little closer to the
mic please so we thank you even closer
okay there you go it's like I'm meating
the mic here um I think representative
Lynn you were actually keying on this
bill I think it's actually poorly
written and and one of the key things I
picked up on was every individual
all right I'm an
individual every individual has a
fundamental right to abortion can I get
an abortion I I don't know that any man
in the world that can get an abortion so
what this doesn't make sense to put into
our constitution every individual can
have a right to
abortion further down I just want to
State and show off here it says after 24
weeks the state may may not prohibit an
abortion okay so that's saying they want
to actually allow abortion up until
birth I mean why does someone want to
kill a baby up until birth I mean if
there's an medical emergency I think we
already got that covered I don't know
why we want to kill the baby up until
birth and then it goes on a little bit
further on there line seven it actually
talks about applicable standard of
care well we've seen through
covid one doctor says it's a vaccine one
says it's not one says the vaccine works
one says it doesn't one says the mass
worked one says it doesn't what what is
the standard of care it's it's very
people I'm with this abortion the
government is saying it has the
authority to allow one group of people
to kill another group of people based on
their own
Prejudice with the bill with this bill
the state is forcing its citizens to
take part in an immoral
act to pass the bill would be to bypass
the moral code of the individual and
would conscript the taxpayers at large
to fund what is against their
conscience I mean just think about a
little bit I mean you you're saying well
there's no money technically but we
could be funding abortion clinics or
clinics in that sense and uh in Grants
and tax money we
collect but at the same time just us
being here making $100 a year it's
costing the taxpayers to actually pass
this constitution
Amendment article two I just want to
read it and I'm sure everybody's well
aware of it natural rights all men have
certain natural essential inherit rights
among which are the enjoying and
defending life and
Liberty defending life and
Liberty not killing life but defending
it it goes on to say acquiring
possessions acquiring possessing in
protecting property and in a word of
seeking and obtaining happiness equality
of rights under the law shall not be
denied or bridged by the state on
account of race Creed color sex or
natural
origin again I think by that first
sentence of everyone of
everybody has a fundamental right to
abortion is actually excluding me
there's no way I can get an abortion
there's just no way this is not a bill
for everybody I think the bill really
needs to be re Rewritten Rewritten and
thought through a little bit more I will
be testifying this afternoon and I get
plenty more information on this and I'll
be sharing it back then but last piece
I'd say is that we know there's you can
look at different Supreme Court rulings
and things of that sort and they kicked
it back to the states to
um for respect for in preservation of
personal life at all stages of
development they kicked it back to us to
decide what that is and I'm saying right
now Life Starts at conception
it just doesn't start at week 2 week 15
week 24 week 36 or any place in between
or if you feel like uh the baby's now
moving it's alive and it's not alive
it's a baby all right thank you I will
take questions but it is hard for me to
hear with my disability so I'll do my
best in hearing the questions if you
want to ask thank you uh questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you committee uh
Shapiro thank you chairman Lynn and
committee members for the record I'm
representative Joe Shapiro representing
chesher
16 better thank
you once again as a man I was unsure
that I had something to offer to a
discussion about reproductive Healthcare
once again again I decided that speaking
on behalf of this bill which will
enshrine the New Hampshire in the New
Hampshire Constitution a woman's right
to make healthc care decisions in
collaboration with their doctor was an
opport opportunity to honor three
generations of amazing women in my
life my mom my wife and my
daughters when I was a very young adult
my first serious girlfriend became
pregnant we were not ready we were
scared and I admit I was
clueless when my girlfriend chose to
have an abortion it was my mother who
came to her side taking her to the
clinic coming to our apart our apartment
to offer healing and support probably
food as well and most important lending
her strength communicating by the force
of her very nature that there was no
reason to feel
ashamed fast forward 10 years another
unplanned pregnancy my wife and I knew
knew we wanted children but we were once
again less than prepared I was a student
we were poor we were betwix and between
several life
transitions we wrestled with what to do
could we provide the stability a child
needed would we have resources to give
our child the life that they deserved
the discussions were long hard
excruciating my wife Nikki was a beacon
of strength confidence and faith in the
future
today our daughter is
38 we are thankful every day for her and
her sister and our two
grandchildren we know that our daughters
will have to wrestle with difficult
life-altering medical situations in fact
they already
have we have full confidence in them my
mom and my wife taught them that women
are fully capable of making the right
decisions for themselves about their
bodies their health care and their well
being they do not need politicians to
decide for them I urge you to vote or to
pass on cacr 23 and Trust the voters to
decide thank
you thank you uh questions for this
witness yes uh representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
did the option of adoption ever enter
your
mind putting a child having a child and
putting them up for adoption we have
thousands millions of people who would
child that is a very personal decision
and a a very personal discussion um in
my case this situation was over 50 years
ago and I cannot honestly say and and I
was very anxious about the whole
situation was a very young person and so
I think that adoption is a a a
a perfectly fine alternative that people
should consider um I can't really I
don't want to speak about what I
considered at that
point other questions for this witness
Oregon so this um we this bill does uh
guarantee uh women or which uh the um or
I could say pregnant person with the uh
right to abortion in a medical emergency
and um as as you know the process of
pregnancy is not a simple one and I know
in this was many years ago it was uh a
member member of my family uh came in at
you know like a week like a week before
the due date and they discovered that
the uh they discovered that the child's
heart was not beating that was many
years ago before they have all that
technology they have now so and um and
those cases still happen today so do do
you feel like a would you say that that
language is necessary to protect people
like like my relative who in that tragic
situation where um you know even you
know we're even like very very late in
the pregnancy and emergency comes up and
and um they have to uh you know you know
the baby is not viable even like after
thanks I'm not exactly sure of what the
question is but what I will say is that
um having children um for me has been
the greatest joy of my life and um I'm
well aware that for others in other
situation it also brings heartbreaking
situations and Incredibly difficult um
decisions and um I think that this
Constitutional Amendment will allow
people with in collaboration with their
doctors to make decisions for themselves
um which I trust them to do thank I
thank the member for his answer and he
did uh he express it more clearly than I
did and I apologize which is that
medical emergencies happened you know
even after the 24 week uh Mark and they
happen all the way you know up to up to
the due date so thank you and this other
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you uh now I senator Perkins
um okay and I if I pronounced your name
wrong I
apologize it's quite all right chair um
it's Senator Perkins quoka it's sor
polish name so just think of POC sorry
about that no worries no worries um
thank you very much all for being here
today um I am here to speak in CA in
support of C
cr23 uh as many of you are aware I have
had two babies two lovely girls so now I
have three while I have been a senator
this issue while often politicized has
not been abstract to me
it doesn't affect some balancing rights
that occur somewhere on a piece of
paper it doesn't affect an abstract
woman that we can all imagine as we have
debated each change to abortion rights
in this state I have been at times 22 24
and 27 weeks pregnant as we have had
that conversation as anyone who is
pregnant knows the tragedies we are
talking about in this conversation are
not
theoretical as a pregnant mother mother
wake up every day and frankly so many
times during the night worrying about
your baby you take innumerable steps
each day you drink decaf coffee take
vitamins eat fruits and vegetables you
avoid alcohol deli meat Sushi soft
cheeses too much sugar and other things
every day because every day and every
minute you think about the baby it lives
inside of your body and you are a mom
each decision I have made during my
three pregnancies starting from the
moment I knew my baby was with me could
hurt them it could help them it could
protect them and that was
true that was true from the first
moments until if I'm lucky I will see my
baby girls grow old be happy as each of
you have always done for your children
we care for these as parents this cacr
gives respect it gives respect to the
women who bear the important
responsibility in our society of
carrying our society's children and
their right to personal physical
autonomy I was so lucky so far not to
find out that something had gone wrong
with any of my babies while I carried
them I cannot tell you the worry I've
had and how like so many other mothers
and terribly Sad Stories We Have Heard
it would simply break my
heart but if that were ever to happen
the best person to make any incredibly
thoughtful and complex decision in that
moment is me with my my spouse with my
partner we have the ability to consult
with our trusted medical providers and
we don't need any other help today this
body will decide whether to ask our
voters to trust me to trust your
colleagues and to trust all New
Hampshire women to make personal private
medical decisions in consultation with
their doctors their family and their
faith if they have
it if you think knowing here sitting
here in this chamber today all the
information that will Happ happen to
someone in that moment I I hope we can
find a path to change your mind thank
you Mr chairman and I welcome any
questions I'm I'm sorry I didn't hear
the last part of what you said I welcome
any questions all right questions for
please seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much for listening today
next I'm going to call on representative
please
thank you Mr
chair good morning honorable members of
the Judiciary Committee for the record
I'm representative Alexis Simpson I
represent exiter new Fields New Market
and stratum thank you for hearing my
testimony on the placing of a
constitutional amendment on the
ballot New Hampshire is one of three
states where abortion is legal but not
protected and New Hampshire is the only
state in New England without this
affirmative
right without explicit State protections
for abortion in statute or in the
Constitution the urgency is real for my
constituents according to recent polling
87% of granite Staters support
reproductive freedom and do not want
State officials to place restrictions on
abortion in New Hampshire we also have a
long and bipartisan tradition of direct
democracy and allowing voters to decide
for themselves the issues that most
impact their
lives we have an obligation to our
constituents the overwhelming majority
of whom believe that decisions about
reproductive and abortion care belong to
pregnant people and the people who
provide them
care without the federal protections
that r Wade provided before it was
overturned granted Staters no abortion
is now not protected at the state level
and not sure if they will continue to
have access to the care they need in New
Hampshire even more so many fear what
the future will look like for their
children and their
grandchildren it may seem that these
fears are
overstated but most of my constituents
watch the national
news they have watched as state after
State across the country has banned
abortion early in pregnancy before
people even know that they are pregnant
and in some cases banned abortion
completely they have heard the stories
of women needing to travel to other
states and having to wait days or even
weeks to access care because their home
state has an abortion
ban and they have heard stories of women
going to court to appeal under
exceptions in their State's laws to then
be denied by their state court and have
to flee to another
state in a time when many people are
uncertain about so many things including
the cost of housing and child care to
name a few losing control over your body
and the ability to make decisions about
the security of your family's future is
scary as a mother myself I understand
these fears there's no decision more
more critical than if when and how to
start and grow a
family I trust patience to make these
decisions and I trust doctors to support
them and to provide Compassionate Care
there is no place in the legislature for
these personal and private
decisions our constituents deserve the
opportunity to make their voices heard I
urge you to vote ought to pass on cacr
23 to send this to the voters of New
Hampshire thank
witness yes representative Perez thank
you um it was stated earlier that no
abortions are performed over 24 weeks I
don't know where that information come
do you know of anyone in the state of
New Hampshire who has been denied an
abortion up to 24 weeks up under the
present
statute so there are two things that I I
think you asked there um no just one
okay it was a preface um do I know let
me just clarify it's a little I'm having
a little trouble hearing so as much as
you can lean into the microphones that
would help me do you know you say
abortion is not protected under the
present uh fetal Life protection act do
you know of
anyone who has been denied an abortion
up to 24 weeks in the state of New
Hampshire under the present fetal Life
protection
act thank you for the question I'm going
to ask you to um ask that with a
provider I think that the doctors who
work with women on a daily basis are
more appropriate to answer that question
thank
you yes representative
k um was it your intention in
co-sponsoring can you just a little bit
closer thanks was it your intention in
co-sponsoring this to allow abortion to
be legal for reasons Beyond life of the
mother or fatal fetal anomalies as is in
current statue now or would you be
supportive of amending to be in
alignment with current statute to allow
up until 24 weeks and then beyond that
with exceptions for the life of the
mother or fatal fetal anomalies so that
it wasn't elective only abortion after
weeks um so let me State clearly I'm not
sure what elective means but uh abortion
doesn't happen after 24 weeks except in
consultation with the medical provider
what we would like is for that to be in
statute that doctors would be able to
use their best judgment their best
medical judgment in helping people who
are pregnant go through complicated um
testing and decision making about what
to do about their pregnancy if it
becomes complicated after 24 weeks right
now they there are um criminal penalties
for doctors and providers after 24 weeks
um that make it very difficult for for
doctors to adhere to best practices with
um without Clarity there so my hope is
that it would be more clear that this is
a kind of decision that belongs not to
politicians but to Providers and
pregnant
people yes follow up you stated that
abortion at after 24 weeks doesn't
happen and I just I wanted to ask are
you aware of the boulder Care Clinic in
Colorado that allows abortion for any
reason after 24
weeks um so I'm sorry if I if I said
that what I'm thought I said and I will
clarify is that um abortion after 24
weeks only happens when there's
complicated situations and a pregnant
person is under the care of their
medical provider and so so I'm going to
ask you to follow up your question with
medical providers that deal with these
complicated situations after 24 weeks I
am speaking to what happens in New
Hampshire I'm unfamiliar with what
Colorado other questions for this
witness yes representative
maners thank you thank you for taking my
question representative Simpson I
believe you testified that can you a
little bit closer to the microphone
thanks I believe that you testified that
in New Hampshire abortion is legal but
not protected and I wondered if you
could expand upon that
please sure so right now in statute
there is nothing that says the right to
an abortion is protected up until 24
weeks in fact the fetal Life protection
act says the opposite nothing about this
act it says nothing about this act
should be construed as a right to
abortion and so our constituents are
very clear what that means which is that
the government
legislators could potentially interfere
before with
legislation of another abortion ban
earlier than 24 weeks at any time what
they would like is for the government to
be out of
decisions about abortion care and in
which I tried to do last year and folks
said they wanted it to go to the voters
so this year I co-sponsored this bill
saying let's let's see what the voters
want let's let them decide what should
law does follow up representative
V thank you so cacr 23 would assure that
abortion is both legal and protected in
New Hampshire is that
correct yes thank you for the question
crca cacr 23 would ensure that it was
both abortion care was both legal and
protected in the law yeah other
questions for the
scripts yes representative
trip uh thank you for taking my question
so uh it it appears that uh just a
little bit closer presumption
say again we can't hear if you can be a
little closer to the microphone thanks
can you hear me now yeah right it it
appears that you have a presumption that
once uh abortion is placed in the
Constitution that it's
protected
uh and but you and the reason for this
is that uh uh if it's not in the
Constitution that it could be repealed
or
amended uh so do you presume that once
it's in the
Constitution it is safe and won't be
removed by subsequent
legislators thank you for the question I
presume it that it will be as safe as we
can make
it thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you thank
sorry that's okay I'll reintroduce
myself so you can hear the correct
pronunciation of my name I'm Katie
peternell state representative represent
wolfboro and Tuftonboro in the beautiful
Lakes Region I am also a tri chair of
the pro-life caucus I'm here to speak in
opposition to cacr um 23 I believe um
that this is a little too soon to be
presenting this cacr the fetal Life
protection act is only 2 years old and I
can testify that when I was campaigning
for office um because people knew that I
was a pro-life candidate one of the
first questions they always asked me was
about abortion and what my stance was
and I would immediately reply ask with
the question of do do you know what the
current law is in the state of New
Hampshire and every single time the
answer was no and I had to explain the
current Statute in our state and every
single time with one exception with one
very angry person who thought that
abortion up until the moment of birth
was completely
acceptable except for that one angry
person every single voter told told me
that they thought 24 weeks was already
extreme and that they would walk it back
to
15 every single person said 24 weeks was
pregnancy so one of the other one of my
issues with the um with the cacr is I'm
not really sure what everyone means and
when I first read it my initial thought
was does that mean a man has a right to
an abortion and if a man has a right to
an abortion does that mean he has a
right to coerce his partner into an
abortion I found that very confusing I
have been told that that couldn't
possibly happen but I find that very
hard to believe I think this is a very
slippery slope that we are going down um
the other thing that I find very
objectionable in the cacr is the actual
number of 20 four weeks now I'm married
to a doctor doesn't mean I am one or
understand anything about being a doctor
but what I do know is how hard he
studies to stay up todate on current
medical practice and he refers medical
the practice of medicine to Fat tie
skinny tie syndrome meaning this year
the fat tie is in fashion and next year
the skinny tie will be in fashion so we
keep all the ties in our our closet
because we don't know which year we're
going to wear the fat one or the skinny
one so I find it very very dangerous
that we're going to put an actual limit
to abortion in the Constitution I what
happens when we find out that the age of
viability is 15 weeks what if we can
someday keep babies alive out of their
mother's womb at 15 weeks we don't know
what medicine is going to do and we
don't know what decisions doctors are
going to make based on this
cacr and if
anything being married to a doctor I
know just enough about medicine that I'm
always very skeptical about which
doctors you choose to
trust and finally on a personal
note I am the product of an adoption two
people chose to have sex and I'm the
consequence of their action
I'm alive and here to tell you about
it I know my birth mother we talk
regularly it's an amazing thing she
feels intense guilt about the fact that
she gave me up for adoption but you know
what I can talk about it with her and at
least she doesn't have to live with the
guilt of knowing that I'm not here and
she can't reach out to me what to talk
about it I also happen to be a woman who
was in a situation with an unwanted
pregnancy and I walked through that
college campus every single day up until
the moment that I gave birth and gave my
own daughter up for adoption and the lie
that women are being told that they
can't do that that they're not strong
enough that they will not graduate from
college they will not have a career and
heaven forbid you might not be a State
Rep someday that's a lie and I'm proof
of the fact that the LIE is a lie thank
you thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank
you uh representative Susan and I know
I'm GNA I'm going to screw up the
pronunciation of this name also and I
apologize Susan of Vander C CasCal is
that right I hope I'm right on
that
good morning Mr chairman thank you I
apologize it is Susan Vandy Castile from
District 25 I'm a registered Republican
and please excuse me I wasn't really
prepared to speak today but I
sponsored this change because I don't
believe this change should even be
discussed I was appalled when it went
into effect in
2020 um I just not factual give it you
in my opinion why a um Republican is
standing up for these rights for the
women in the state of New Hampshire
because I'm a citizen of the United
States I live in New Hampshire the Live
Free or Die
State I value everyone's opinion which
everyone here and I got to tell you it's
a very personal personal decision when
you're in that situation I was a um
geriatric pregnancy and I had a choice
in late term if I was termin or keep
it's very personal no woman wants to
stand there and defend themselves in
front of you their colleagues every
resident in the state so I believe we
have more to change in the state of New
Hampshire to make it great than talk
about personal very personal
decisions I do not know of any woman
that has had an abortion after 25 weeks
everyone that I have asked they cannot
tell me if they know anyone
however I would never judge that person
God is the only one and God We Trust
will judge that person so I think we
should send this bill this change to the
voters of the State of New Hampshire and
let them speak no change should be made
it if I had my way I'd remove it
strictly right from the constitution of
New Hampshire so please thank you very
much for allowing me to speak I wasn't
prepared but it kind of upsets me that
we're standing here discussing these
personal matters instead of State
matters for elected officials not
politicians thank you thank you
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
Mr chair uh next I'm going to call on uh
Lum good morning
morning my name is Dick llum I am a life
director for the dairy Nights of
Columbus I am here to oppose
c23 relating to the right for an
abortion what's going on here
Representatives even though abortions in
our loud before 24 weeks
ci23 will will allow abortions to be
performed after 24 weeks if deem
necessary by a doctor excuse me but I
don't know if this board is aware that
abortions are now being performed by
doctors at plan Parenthood AB
braries like at P Parenthood on Penacook
Street in Manchester in other locations
even right here on Main Street in konet
so I guess an abortion would be an easy
enough just walk into one of those life
centers life centers for The Unborn and
request an abortion for whatever reason
anyway I support life from the moment of
conception and like a life God I stress
the word life I and other people of like
mind will always TR out a life
alternative to Future mothers and
fathers and give them
alternatives to fut and give them
Alternatives which plann Parenthood
doesn't do Alternatives like birri real
choices and Penny cook healthc Care
Center in Manchester and other great
life
organizations right here in New
Hampshire that support mothers and their
unborn and by the way don't charge for
their services ever ever abies like
plant parent and other killer clinics
don't give anything but just take and
only take making tidy profit while doing
this so-called medical
procedure and that is the atrocity of
abortion thank God our mothers decided
for life and Please be aware of wolves
who prowl about in sheep's
clothing preaching woman's retroductive
Healthcare as a reason to abort unborn
babies in a weapon of choice this time
is
c23 thank you for your time thank you
very much sir questions for this
Lee hi good morning chairman Lynn and
members of the house reary sorry yeah
thank you if you could just get a little
closer to the mic thanks good morning
chairman Lynn and members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is Dr Amy
Lee I'm a New Hampshire resident and a
practicing OBGYN resident physician as a
resident physician I have completed my
medical degree and I'm now in the
process of
specialization called
residency after four years of residency
I will be an independent
provider I'm here today to express my
support for cacr
23 when applying to residency programs I
like countless other medical graduates
was looking for the assurance that I
would get training in abortion care
during
residency I will be transparent in
saying that the lack of protection to
abortion access in New Hampshire law
gave me serious pause when considering
coming to the state for
training let me be very
clear the training of residents in New
Hampshire is a powerful recruitment tool
nationally 57% more than half of
residents will ultimately practice in
the state where they did their
residency in New Hampshire for the past
5 years we have had a 65% retention rate
and we do not want that excellent
retention to
change we know that states with
restrictive abortion bans or limited
access to reproductive Health Care have
seen a drop in the number of OBGYN
residency applications
those states are losing a valuable pool
of future providers during a time where
the healthcare Workforce is plagued by a
shortage
nationally when 50 when
43.9% of current OBGYN residents lack
access to abortion care training New
Hampshire as a state that provides that
opportunity for training attracts
residents and in turn future providers
for our patients and your constituents
the protections afforded by cacr 23
should the New Hampshire voters get the
opportunity to weigh in on this crucial
reproductive healthcare issue would draw
future providers for residency and
encourage them to establish roots in New
Hampshire we want those New Hampshire
trained doctors to have all the tools
they need to provide evidencebased care
for your constituents and that includes
abortion
care
for these reasons I urge the house
Judiciary Committee to recommend passing
the cacr 23 thank you for your time and
considerations I will not be taking
questions thank you very
much she said she doesn't want to take
questions thank you all right uh next
uh she said she wouldn't take questions
um next Dr o young
please
thank you Judge Lynn and chairman and
committee for allowing me to speak this
morning my name is Dr o
young uh I am testifying in favor of
cacr
23 I'm a retired obstetrician
gynecologist practiced in this community
for 40 years
and taught Dartmouth medical students
time I also am a past president of the
New Hampshire Medical Society and I
continue to serve on their General board
representing all the Obstetricians in
this
state I just have one story for you my
older partner was a very
conservative
Republican just out of training my wife
and I came with our Three Sons to
conquer looking for an Oban
practice he smiled at me told me how
glad he was to know how badly I needed a
job we shook hands over a
$35,000 salary and and I have been
forever
grateful it was a real privilege to
practice in this community with such a
Beloved
Physician he lasted 50 years he had a
deep respect for
women which I think started watching his
mom raise five
Sons as a young Widow his father died
when he was six in the granite quaries
of bury
Vermont he once said to me my mom bought
a broom and rote it
hard he went to the University of
Vermont on a full
scholarship and he lived in the
DI the Episcopal
dasis he was a devout Christian and he
remained a religious man throughout his
life when St Paul's Church Bur to the
ground he spent much of his time and his
treasures rebuilding that church he
cherished that
church after college he went on to
medical school at University of Vermont
then did a year of internship like we
used to do back then and finally ended
up spending two years in the Air Force
he was stationed at Lauren Air Force
Base in northern Maine when he got there
they asked him they said would you like
to be our obstetrician or or
pediatrician he candidly said you know I
really like screaming women more than I
like screaming
kids so they made him their obstetrician
and it was there he fell in love with
taking care of women and delivering
their babies and it was because of that
experience he went on for four years of
training as an OBGYN specialist at
Women's Hospital in New York
City and it was during that time in the
late 1950s he saw many young women die
die of an overwhelming
infection having had an illegal botched
back alley
abortion and some of those women left
children at home as
orphans it came to
him that abortions must be safe and
legal he argued that women will always
always seek desperately seek abortion
care whether it's legal or
illegal the unnecessary deaths he
witnessed during his training left a
mark on his heart his mind and his
soul it was plain to him that abortion
should only be performed by skilled
conditions US Supreme Court roie Wade
landmark decision in
1973 brought great relief to him besides
delivering thousands of babies days and
nights he provided abortion care in our
office at conquered hospital and at the
feminist Health Center now called
equality Health
Center motivated by what he'd
experienced during his training he
stayed intent on making
abortion safe and
private I often asked him I said how can
you vote for a republican candidate
who's openly opposed to
abortion his answer was always the
same he said o abortion is not about
politics it's about health care it's
Women and few knew better than him his
feelings never
wavered even though he was threatened by
protesters at our office and at his
home he would be appalled that politics
has crept into the judicial
branch of our
democracy and that with the do's
decision we reversed roie Wade in June
of
he would find it hard to believe that
after 50 years the right to privacy and
safety and deciding about a woman's
health her family and her future has
been taken away from
her he knew that the decision to
terminate a
pregnancy was a difficult decision
deeply private and should remain between
a woman and her
caregiver
that medicine is about
caring for human beings it's not about
politics it's not about
ideology he believed that everything we
can
do to give women control over their
bodies enhances their health and their
freedom and makes the world a better
place if you were alive
today he'd you'd be standing
here as a man of great faith as a very
conservative
Republican and he would be urging you to
support this amendment he would be
asking you to enshrine for New Hampshire
women the right to an abortion I too
urge you to support CA
cr23 and amend our New Hampshire
Constitution
thank you thank you uh Dr Young let's
let's please let's hold the Applause
okay questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on representative
Matthew Simon and I uh I note that there
are over 20 people who yet who who
desire to speak and so for that reason
I'm going to ask you to please limit
your comments to 3 minutes yes thank you
Mr chair members of the committee I know
that you guys do this year in and year
out and you've heard every argument that
can be made on this topic and so uh I
would just like to spend my few minutes
just calling to uh memory um a couple of
important points that I haven't heard
brought up by committee members in
conversation as to the part that uh
deals with after 24 weeks which we refer
to as the fetal Life protection act here
at the state house um we have mentioned
that there's an exception for um fetal
anomalies incompatible with life uh and
that there is one for the life of the
mother but we have not g into the fact
that it goes beyond the life of the
mother and into the health of the mother
um the statute
um I just had it
sorry um the pregnancy will have created
a serious risk of substantial and
irreversible impairment of a m major
bodily function as defined in the rsas
so any that puts a major bodily function
of a female at risk who's pregnant and
having a child is also o grounds for an
abortion after the 24 we Mark in the
state of New Hampshire it's not just the
life of the mother if there looks like
there's going to be a serious
complication to something it's also
grounds um so just by way of reminder
there the second is just the nature of
the debate um and for people on my side
of this issue uh and I know you know my
wife sent me with her blessing this
morning it's difficult as a man
sometimes speaking on this topic but my
wife and every woman in my household
that I uh agrees with with me on this
issue um
we recognize that pregnancy bringing a
new human being into the world is a is a
terribly difficult task it's dangerous
there are a lot of complications and
worries and fears and potentials we
can't see the future we don't know
what's coming and uh and in some in some
cases in the future when we look back we
wish we'd made different decisions than
the ones that we had made but in the
moment I understand all of the dangers
and complications and my sympathy is
there
100% if it was simply a matter of making
decisions based on the healthcare
choices between a a woman and her
physician I'd be out in fact you could I
you know me I'm one of the most pro-life
people in this house um you could
convince me to switch sides it is
possible all you have to do is convince
me that in order to solve our problems
we're not killing innocent
children just just make that argument
convince me on that point I'll switch
sides that's what we're concerned about
and that's why the legislature is
involved the legislature is involved is
because half of us make the argument
that we're killing innocent children in
order to solve our problems to solve our
worries and our fears and our
complications and the ways in which we
might our life might go poorly in the
future and Mr chair members of the
committee I would submit to you today
that's just not an acceptable
option and if we started imp
implementing those same kinds of
standards to people after they were born
I think we'd be mortified with what we
were doing and I see no difference
between the two thank you for your time
thank you questions for the this
witness seeing none thank you of the
comme next I'm going to call on uh Liz
Canada
please good morning honorable members of
the House Judiciary Committee for the
record my name is Liz Canada I'm the
advocacy director at Planned Parenthood
New Hampshire action fund and Planned
Parenthood of Northern New England and
we're here in strong support of cacr
23 after the US Supreme Court overturned
roie Wade in June of
2022 abortion has been on the ballot
very explicitly in Six States Kansas
Kentucky Vermont California Michigan and
just two months ago Ohio now two of
those measures were to further restrict
strict abortion in their states but the
other four were to enshrine protections
into their state
constitution now those states have very
different processes in order to amend
their constitutions some allow
signatures to be collected and ballot
initiatives we don't have that in New
Hampshire but the question was still the
same and in all four of those states
which are arguably very different from
one another voters overwhelmingly
supported abortion rights approving free
from the government in personal
decision- making now here in New
Hampshire we've enjoyed for so long a
bipartisan support of Reproductive
Rights here in the State House abortion
rights are supported by a vast majority
of granite Staters from all political
backgrounds Granite Staters want their
lawmakers they want you to take the
steps needed to protect abortion rights
in the New Hampshire Constitution which
means passing the
cacr in fact a recent poll in in New
Hampshire showed that
64% of Republicans say there should be a
right to get an abortion in every state
cacr 23 would send this question to the
voters it would allow the voters of New
Hampshire to decide on whether our state
constitution should be amended to
explicitly include abortion and to stop
any further abortion bans from the New
Hampshire
legislature this cacr embodies Granite
State values of freedom and privacy and
it shows that we trust
doctors I know it is a high bar to amend
the New Hampshire Constitution it should
be to amend the state constitution but
we know that a vast majority of graned
Staters agree with this and that they
want that right enshrined in there to
protect it for future
Generations so we encourage you to vote
aop pass on cacr 23 thank you thank you
questions for this
witness yes representative kab
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I wanted to ask you a
similar question as I've asked
others would you be supportive of an
amendment to this that allowed abortion
through 24 weeks and then beyond for
reasons of life of the mother or fatal
fetal anomaly but protected the life of
the baby the that's viable and healthy
thank you for that question
representative so I don't want to speak
on any amendment I haven't seen so I
can't say one way or the other on that
what I will say is that we are seeing
across the country how exceptions that
are written out in that way don't
necessarily work on the ground an
example that is very recent and you may
have heard of this example already is
Kate Cox in Texas there is an exception
in the incredibly restrictive abortion
ban in Texas that
she that she fell under that she was
able to access abortion under that
exception based on the way that the
exception was written out but when she
challenged what the courts were saying
the courts denied her that care they
were not trusting doctors and so she had
to leave her State because of how the
exception was being
interpreted the way that this cacr is
written removes that it says we trust
doctors and patients to make this
private medical decision and so we
support cacr 23 thank you other
questions for This
Ss seeing none thank you very much well
oh I'm sorry representative Perez I'm
didn't see you thank
you last year when we were discussing
abortion I specifically asked a um
representative from Planned Parenthood
at up to what gestation they allowed
abortions and it was 15 weeks that has
gone up in the state of New Hampshire I
just spoke to the dairy Clinic yesterday
and they allow it up to 21
weeks call them up to 21 weeks in clinic
in clinic um I just wonder I'm going to
ask
again
why since you represent these groups why
are we talking about a 24 we
constitutional and this is New Hampshire
we're talking about we're not talking
about Tex Tas we're not talking about
Michigan we're talking about New
Hampshire why the 24 weeks nobody seems
to be able to answer
that thank you for the question
representative so to be clear um the
gational limits that we're talking about
at the Planned Parenthood Northern New
England Health Centers uh Manchester is
to 18 weeks Derry just recently um
started being able to offer abortion
care up to 11 weeks through medication
abortion you'll hear more about all of
those in a later bill actually so we we
can hold on that till later because I
know my colleague is here to address
that very thing later today why 24 weeks
what this uh cacr does is embodies what
you're saying representative it's not a
Texas cacr it's not a constitutional
amendment that would be for another
state it is for us here of what we've
had these debates and discussions on
over the past few years and really
embodies what granted Staters want they
want the right to abortion explicitly
listed in the state constitution so
there is no confusion
and they want to trust doctors in the
state constitution so that a further
legis a future legislature can't roll
back those restrictions any further like
we're seeing later today in those
bills other question yes representative
manage thank you Mr chair Miss Canada
another witness testified that it's too
soon for a constitutional amendment I'm
wondering if you disagree with that and
if so why thank you representative for
that question I do disagree that it is
too soon I think we need it now more
than ever with roie Wade gone there are
no federal or state protections for
abortion in New Hampshire we're the only
state in New England that doesn't have
any protections Granite Staters expect
their lawmakers to take action another
poll shows that 87% of granite Staters
want action taken by lawmakers and
support reproductive freedom and so this
is the time to do it this is the time to
demonstrate our commit ment to Granite
Staters and what they are asking
lawmakers to
do other other questions yes
representative
ter yeah thank you for taking my
question um do you see um in terms of a
constitutional amendment versus the law
that is existing today that they come
from different uh sides of the same
argument the Constitutional Amendment
essentially being the people turned out
to the voters prohibiting us the
lawmakers from passing laws within a
certain parameter that restrict their
freedoms and Liberties versus a law
which in this case tends to come on the
other side and per permit those
restrictions and Define them and is that
a framework within which you can view
the need for a constitutional me thank
you for the question yes I mean the cacr
and sending it to the voters is hearing
directly from them on this matter and
putting this question forward so that
you know we see how abortion is on the
ballot in elections in general but this
would be very explicit do you think that
the right to abortion should be in the
Constitution so that a future
legislature can't roll back restrictions
anymore or in you know add more
restrictions in the future I think it is
incredibly imperative that a question is
sent to the voters like
that other yes uh representative
testerman
this C this question came up earlier and
I'm not sure if we we got an answer to
it uh it says right up early that the
every individual has a fundamental right
to
abortion uh doesn't say women doesn't
say men doesn't say whatever trans
whatever is this an attempt to get sort
of an artificial
way of you putting that decision or that
thought into the minds of people uh as
part of this abortion
bill I couldn't hear the last part of
your question but I heard the I think I
heard the concept of it which is using
the word individual instead of men or
women or trans men or whatever you you
know at the list that you gave um every
individual individuals are Granite
Staters whether you're pregnant now or
pregnant in the future you should have
the right to abortion so I think that is
very clearly spelled out that if
somebody walks into The Ballot Box on
Election Day they'll see this language
know exactly what it covers which is an
individual's own right to their own
bodily autonomy that it trusts doctors
and they would vote in
support thank
you other questions yes representative
hon so I have a question about the
legislative history of this um I guess
guess I'll make uh two questions first
of all isn't isn't this 24 weeks
something that was fairly recently put
in the statute law and actually um I'm
not personally 100% sure whether 24 is
the appropriate number but there was
this what isn't this something that was
just very recently put into the statute
law with I think extremely broad
bipartisan
support thank you for the question so if
I'm understanding it's you're asking is
the 24-week conversation essentially
very new to New Hampshire and yes it was
passed in 2020 21 um there were two
bills that were introduced in 2021 in
the house Judiciary one was a 24-week
ban and it passed through the house and
it was uh debated in the Senate and then
put into the state budget it it went
into effect on January 1st 20122 and
then in the 2022 legislature some parts
of it were rolled back so it removed the
mandatory ultrasounds and it added fatal
fetal diagnoses which you know we've
heard already here too so yes it is very
very recent this entire debate prior to
that um prior to 2021 New Hampshire
trusted doctors and patients and so the
cacr would return us to that
point other questions oh followup to
this and isn't yes representative gon
we're going I'm sorry follow
sores and with the other issue about
we're equaling about the mean the word
individual but isn't
really going far back behind 2021
basically probably since New Hampshire
the state EV state law always
represented
that the person who the person who
actually is pregnant has a much
different uh much higher stake in the
pregnancy than somebody who's you know
merely a family member even you know the
father or whoever so isn't hasn't there
always been a long-standing presumption
of the law that the person who's
actually pregnant um is much more has
like a much uh deeper uh relationship
with the issue than just somebody else
who's another uh family member associate
of the person
thank you representative yes I think it
all comes down to the person who's
pregnant their own individual body yes
thank you
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for your testimony in the bill
the language of the bill it says the
state cannot prohibit restrict delay or
penalize this right prior to 24 weeks
unless it is justified by a compelling
State interest achieved by the least
restrictive means what is the definition
of a compelling State interest and can
you give me an example of one thank you
for the question my understanding is
that would be determined by the court if
that were something that would to go
forward so I would defer to attorneys
I'm not an attorney but that's my
understanding other questions for this
witness saying none thank you very much
thank you uh next I'm going to call on
sorry his read okay yes
Courtney Reed and again I'm going to ask
you please uh try to keep your testimony
you sorry I have a lot
of
papers
thank you members of the committee my
name is Courtney Reid I serve as policy
Advocate with the ACLU of New Hampshire
and I'm providing a statement of support
for cacr 23 which would enshrine the
right to abortion in New Hampshire state
constitution cacr 23 would give voters
the opportunity to affirm that in the
granite state the right to personal
reproductive autonomy should not be
denied this is one of the most effective
things that New Hampshire can do to
protect the reproductive rights of
everyone in the state and it's more
critical now than ever as I'm sure many
of you are aware uh to protect these
rights in state law or in the state
constitution after the Dos decision in
recent years nationally we've seen the
Reproductive Rights landscape fall into
chaos where 60 plus clinics have closed
over 20 states have restricted or banned
abortion and now one in five women are
traveling out of state to receive
abortion care however there are states
that have taken affirmative actions to
protect the right to abortion either
through state law or through
Constitutional Amendments like cacr 23
in states that have brought
constitutional protections to the voters
like California Michigan Ohio and our
neighboring state of
Vermont constituents have had
overwhelming support to put this right
into the
Constitution and without any federal
protections to abortion these
constitutional rights at the state level
are more important than ever because
right now we're just one election away
or one bill away from making access to
abortion in New Hampshire all the more
difficult when someone finds thems
unable to access an abortion uh they
might have uh increased difficulty
escaping poverty or they might have to
to put their education on hold they
might have to change their life plans or
they might have uh increased difficulty
leaving an abusive partner there's
research that also shows uh for
individuals that have not uh had access
to an abortion four years down the line
uh the prevalence of poverty is
increased this is called the turnaway
study I referenced it in my
citations I want to underscore my
support and the ACLU of New Hampshire
support for this amendment as
reproductive of freedom is essential to
fulfilling the promise of equality and
self-determination and the granite
States
principles of the right to privacy and
individual liberty I also wanted to
speak a bit to the uh least restrictive
means uh language that's in the
cacr um the least restrictive language
provides uh what would be a strict
scrutiny test for the right to an
abortion um as folks might be aware no
right is 100% guaranteed sometimes
rights compete with one another um but
this language prioritizes the right to
an abortion when it is challenged for
say the right um to the parent so this
extra language gives the right to an
abortion an additional protection when
it is perhaps challenged in the courts
and that's why uh the ACLU is uh in
support of it so I'm happy to take any
questions thank you questions for this
Perez how does the
life I thank you for your question I
don't think that that is something that
falls in the scope of the work that the
ACLU
does follow up
well in the definition of the ACLU they
say they are their purpose is to defend
and preserve the individual rights and
Liberties guaranteed to every person in
this country by the Constitution and
laws of the United States I'm just
wondering what their definition is when
person thank you for your question um I
I think would be best for me to get back
to you and working with an attorney on
that but I do want to note that the ACLU
has always supported the prevailing
right of the pregnant individual to have
the autonomy to make reproductive
decisions thank you other questions for
this
witness representative
gon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony since you represent a
bunch of attorneys maybe you would know
or you could get back to us with the
answer you say in your testim Tony here
after the Supreme Court overturned Row
versus Wade we no longer have a federal
constitutional right to an
abortion when was the Constitution
amended to allow for or to to give the
right for an abortion when was the
Constitution amended again to take away
that right and are you conflating are
these attorneys conflating Row versus
Wade which is a Judicial precedent with
a constitutional right so a little
disingenuous language here just want to
know thank you for your question
representative um in the
1970s when roie
Wade was ruled the courts interpreted
that the right to privacy was a
constitutional right um the do's
decision overturned that that ruling and
the courts had stated that it's up to
states to take independent actions to
protect the right to abortion as
interpreted um which is why this
amendment is so important thank you
other questions for this
we seeing none thank you very much thank
please good
morning members of the committee my name
is Laura gandia and I'm here
representing Cornerstone action and in
speaking in opposition to cacr
23 the Constitution is not nor should it
ever be used as a political porn
amendments to the Constitution should
seek Justice for the benefit of the
common good should unite us as free
people not divide us the weaponization
of the New Hampshire Constitution as
outlined in
c23 tears at the very heart and soul of
our Republic U we are called to promote
charity and human dignity for the common
good a common purpose for the
Constitution to serve its purpose it
must act as a coherent unified working
document any amendment should Echo and
support its purposes an amendment cannot
survive if it disrupts or conflicts with
other other Provisions
ca23 represents challenges as an
unconstitutional Amendment
the amendment must be harmonious with
the body of the
Constitution it cannot be internally
inconsistent if it is then such
amendment should be declared
unconstitutional in the do's decision
the court noted that the constitution
makes no reference to abortion no such
right is implicitly protected by the
Constitution or any constitutional
provision an abortion in and of itself
is contct to the spirit and intent of
the Constitution the court recognized
that there are rights that are not
explicitly mentioned which can Garner
constitutional support provided those
rights are deeply rooted in this
nation's history and implicit in the
concept of ordered Liberty the New
Hampshire Constitution makes that
abundantly clear in part one article two
of our constitution all men have certain
natural essential and inherent rights
the drafters of our constitution
understood that there were certain
rights not all rights that are worthy of
constitutional protection abortion is
not a right contemplated by the
Constitution nor is it a right
contemplated by the 14th Amendment it is
not deeply rooted in our nation's
history or is it implicit in the concept
of ordered Liberty it is critically
different from any other right that the
US Supreme Court held worthy of
constitutional Liberty protection when
the 14th amendment was adopted three4 of
the states made abortion a crime at all
stages our Bill of Rights Article One
States as part of its purpose all
government is instituted for the general
good General good for all article two
calls for the protection enjoyment and
defense of life and Liberty this cacr
defies and conflicts with these articles
creating dissension Discord and
inconsistencies there is no rational
basis for the institution of this
amendment or how it is Central to
Liberty and dignity even if someone
believes that abortion is a right
contemplated by the Constitution a look
at the New Hampshire state constitution
article three dictates the hitting of
the breakes
article three provides when one enters
into a state of society they surrender
up some of their natural rights in order
to ensure the protection of others the
others can in and clearly should be
viewed as the children in our
society to include those children living
in their mother's
wom further as already has been stated
the language of cacr 23 is extremely
problematic the amendment's language
proposes that the state cannot prohibit
abortion prior to 24 weeks unless it is
justified by compelling State interests
achieved by list by the least
restrictive means attempting to apply a
strict scrutiny standard assumes without
justification that abortion is a
fundamental right the New Hampshire
Constitution clearly states that there
there are certain unalienable rights
further the fundamental rights that
demand strict scrutiny has been
identified and they include such rights
as freedom of speech voting laws that
discriminate based on the race not the
aborting of our children you know ma'am
could I just ask you I've sort of
requested people to try to keep it to
three minutes and I think you're
considerably over that now I'd
appreciate it if you could sort of sum
up thank you uh New Hampshire has
recognized the rights of parents to care
for their
as a fundamental liberty interest
protected by article
one by part one Article 2 of the New
Hampshire Constitution it's impossible
to reconcile the wellestablished
interest of the New Hampshire
Constitution with aborting our children
for the sake of
Liberty and the CICS further states that
after 21 weeks that the Physicians shall
apply applicable standards of care and
making a professional judgment this
language is vague subjective and
undefinable
the language does not even attempt to
categorize or set perimeters for where
it is necessary or what the applicable
standard of care would be to allow
abortion up to birth to whom is this
standard being applied is it for the
baby as we know doctors now take
Extraordinary Measures in their state of
care to protect I please ask you to sum
up please you're you're quite a bit over
sure this amendment would desecrate and
defile a constitution resulting in a
dishonor to our found ERS and all the
citizens of our great state including
our most precious children a vote of
inexpedient to legislate is the only
just proper and appropriate action thank
you questions for this wit questions for
this wit I I don't have a question
specifically although um I thank her for
her she took put a lot of effort in the
testimony and it's very
thought-provoking I just wanted to
welcome uh rent former president gandia
back because she um there's I think
there's maybe only one other person that
table who served with her but like um
it's always good to see a former
legislature come back cuz we're always
uh we're always we're a family we're
very large family we disagree about lots
of things but we're we're still a family
and it's always good to uh always good
to see you again so so thank you we
guess we'll be seeing you some more if
you're working for Cornerstone so thank
you I thank you for that recognition and
it's nice to be back thanks thank you
very much man other
questions seeing none thank you all
right uh Heather Stockwell please
she just EXC me she just had to step out
okay I'll we skip her her testimony to
get C so I can give it to you she had to
leave to oh okay so you want to bring
your bring you want to bring that up or
is she going to come back and testify
she went to medical appointment oh sure
so why don't you give us okay all right
please
and again Mr Hennessy I would ask you if
you please you confine your remarks to
about three minutes okay please thank
you Mr chair hi my name is Jason
Hennessy I'm here to represent New
Hampshire right to life uh New
Hampshire's largest single issue prolife
organization and as well as the many
many many pro-life uh New Hampshire
residents so we are we are completely
opposed to the cacr 23 the biggest thing
the first thing to mention is that this
would legalize abortion through
birth and that is that is a very big
deal that is out of touch with 90% of
Americans according to a Harvard Harris
poll from 2022 as well as 70% of New
Hampshire
residents now if you don't doubt that
this is abortion till birth you just
need to take a look at um at the bill
the bill says that abortion after 24
weeks is allowed with a physician's
opinion if you if you were to attend the
uh the hearing for a very similar Bill
cacr 24 last week in the Senate you
would have heard Physicians from New
Hampshire saying that abortion is always
okay that in their opinion it's always
an option so and it and so if you
believe that elective abortions don't
happen after that after that stage in
the third trimester just need to look at
the statistics from other states um even
though there aren't very many of these
third trimester abortions there are
there are statistics that say that
roughly half of them uh give or take are
what we would call electives so not for
the health or for rape or incest or
those types of things there are also
clinics across the country that uh
advertise that they will do8 n eight and
N month
abortions uh for whatever reason you
want so this bill is
Extreme the the state has a duty to
defend
life and and make no mistake these are
especially especially in the third
trimester these are healthy babies these
are babies that could be born these are
uh babies that could be that feel pain
that could be given up for at a because
of our safe haven law nobody's required
to raise a child under a safe haven law
in New Hampshire we've had for over 20
years now you can take you can drop a
child off at a hospital for any reason
no questions asked and that's on top of
of adoption I want to mention the story
of Brooke Fisk Brook was 17 weeks
pregnant with her son macki she visited
her uh the child's father to say will
you help me raise this child in return
he put He put chemical abortion drugs
into her tea and she drank it and then
lost her
child this this Constitutional Amendment
as the chair pointed out gives
individuals the right to abort it
doesn't say who whose child they can
abort would this legalize the
victimization and oppression of women
that is a question that needs to be
answered there was another victim in
Wisconsin and and she and she lost
several pregnancies before finally
catching her V her her oppressor and
then now thankfully he's in
jail but she had several
miscarriages how many people you know
how many times how many people would
take a look at this law say oh I have
some protection if I get arrested for
this most people probably wouldn't get
caught so this this bill offers nothing
to support women who want their
child and it oppresses controls and
victimizes pregnant
women thank you very much sir you're
you're at uh you're at your time
questions for this W thank you Mr chair
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much thank you next I
would call on uh Katie d'angelus
please
thank
you honorable committee members of house
Judiciary thank you for the opportunity
to address you
today my name is Katie dangeles and I'm
a resident of Nottingham and I'm here to
express my support for cacr 23
today I'm here to share my
story I'm thankful every day for my two
wonderful
children my pregnancies were relatively
uneventful which I am so incredibly
grateful for my deliveries on the other
hand were a very different story while
both were difficult my last delivery was
especially
harrowing I won't go into specifics uh
because much of it I'm still working uh
through today with the help of my
therapy
IST however the crucial point is that
during that labor there was a very real
moment when I didn't believe either I or
my child would be walking out of that
hospital I've always been pro- Choice
even before delivering my son but it was
this experience that taught me two
inalienable
truths the first is that we are so
fortunate to have fantastic healthcare
providers that live in New Hampshire
our providers use their knowledge and
experience to provide invaluable care to
the people across our state it is
providers like the ones who have
testified before you that saved my life
and my son's life that
day they're the reason that I'm here and
able to testify and I will forever be
grateful the second truth is that
decisions about my body are rightfully
mine alone as I am the only one who
truly knows what's at
stake during both of my pregnancies and
deliveries I was incredibly fortunate to
have the protection of
row its fall is one of the deciding
factors in my decision not to become
pregnant again I see the current bills
legislators have proposed in the New
Hampshire house I hear the genuine fear
among the providers in our medical
community who have
testified the last thing that I would
want my provider to worry about is being
able to prove in a court of law that
their conduct was necessary to save my
life or whether my life was indeed ever
in danger to begin with I don't want my
life to come down to an uncertain legal
landscape when I have two children who
need their mom to come home to them at
the end of the
day I know this must be an incredibly
challenging job you represent people
across the granite state that have a
diverse range of
beliefs thank you for all of your work
on our
behalf but I'm here today to ask that
you let me help help make this decision
that you let us the people of New
Hampshire make this decision trust us to
make the right decision for ourselves
and pass cacr
23 thank you for your time and
consideration I won't be taking any
questions thank you all right um Lynn uh
Lynn
painer
problem good
morning chair and members of the
Judiciary Committee thank you for
hearing my testimony my name is Dr Lynn
Lind paintner I live in conquer I'm here
to support cacr 23 I'm convinced that we
need a con Constitutional Amendment
based on my professional work and on my
personal experiences which I'll
summarize for you I'm a retired doctor
not an obstetrician I'm an internist
even before I was a doctor I was a
nurse in that role in particular but
also as an internist I counseled many
pregnant women who came for me about for
information about their pregnancies
about options and I included legal
abortion in my information that I shared
with
them and these conversations taught me
so much about the multitude of
circumstances which led some of those
women to choose abortion we've heard
some of these stories today I heard
about multiple con contraceptive
failures I heard about sexual coercion
inside and outside of
marriage I heard about the word worry of
another mouth to feed within the P
powerlessness of
poverty previous life-threatening
pregnancy complications as we've just so
eloquently heard and many many more
personal stories and these women were
not
selfish they needed health
care I'm also a mother of two precious
daughters and I'm a person who sadly
experienced a spontaneous
abortion that's the medical term for a
miscarriage when I was 16 weeks along in
my very first pregnancy my body went
into
labor I began to deliver my farto
premature fetus my
son I was
bleeding my obstetrician performed an
office procedure a dilation in curage we
call it a DNC and that safely stopped my
bleeding that same DNC procedure is also
used safely to terminate pregnancies in
the
office what would have happened to me if
a 15-week abortion ban had been in place
at that time would she have acted in
time would she have been willing to
perform a potentially questionable
procedure my doctors are not martyrs
if they're being facing being called a
felon losing their medical
license they don't do
it they're not reassured in the moment
when there's
urgency by a vaguely worded exception to
protect the life of the mother the idea
that these exceptions that you write in
cover it all is simply not accurate in
world these doctors have families to
feed so what do they do they leave the
state they don't come here to train we
lose
Obstetricians labor and delivery Suites
are closing throughout New
Hampshire for many
reasons or they stop performing health
care that women need women can die as a
result and right now today there are
actual court cases in Texas and Idaho
over the issue of weather emergency
abortions to save the life of the mother
can be required you know what man' I
again we're getting you're sort of over
your three minute you're over your 3
minute time I just ask you if you could
sum up if you would I will thank you
we've heard a lot of the reasons that a
constitutional amendment is important I
support those reasons in protecting life
we need CAC R23 which would ensure that
this nuanced and complex healthc care
decision can be made privately and
confidentially and we need in such such
a
personal situation and personal issue to
hear from the voters as has already been
eloquently expressed today so I will
close by urging you to support
CRC CAC R23 let Granite Staters vote in
New Hampshire and I thank you very much
for your time thank you questions for
this
witness seeing none I'm next going to
call on Executive counselor Cindy
warmington
please
there thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um good morning
esteemed members of the board of the
house Judiciary Committee my name is
Cindy warmington I live in conquer and I
serve as our state's executive counselor
for the second district I come before
you today asking that each of you
support the fundamental freedom of
granite Staters to access safe legal
abortion care and more specifically vote
ought to pass on this Constitutional
Amendment concurrent resolution
23 since the United States Supreme Court
overturned the long standing protections
guaranteed by roie Wade millions of
Americans have faced restrictions on
their fundamental freedom to access safe
legal abortion writes that Generations
before them previously came to rely upon
following that decision in June of
2022 State houses all across the country
have moved to obstruct reproductive
Freedom including right here in New
Hampshire where Republicans recently
introduced a 15-day abortion ban
attempts like these are dangerous to the
health and well-being of the women of
our state and must Must Be Stopped
simply put freedom for women starts with
being able to make our own reproductive
Health Care decisions to plan prevent
and space our own pregnancies the
ability to access comprehensive
reproductive health care including birth
control and abortion care is essential
to protecting the health and well-being
of all this constitutional Amendment
would ensure all granite sters have the
freedom to make their own personal
reproductive Health Care decisions
without government
interference there have been repeat
there has been repeated evidence and
public polling that show a vast majority
of granite Staters support reproductive
freedom and want State leaders to
protect their right to abortion care yet
New Hampshire is currently the only
state in New England that does not
protect abortion rights we must change
that this is an opportunity to enshrine
reproductive Freedom into our state
constitution and make New Hampshire a
place where we explicitly trust women
and their doctors to make their own
personal health care decisions not
politicians we cannot wait we must act
today to protect our fundamental freedom
and once again I urge each of you to put
the fundamental freedom of granite
Staters above politics and vote ought to
pass on this Constitutional Amendment
thank you thank you questions for this
witness thank you seeing none thank you
uh next I'm going to call on uh Aaron
joerger
please thank you Mr Speaker
and all of the committee members for
allowing me thank you for the promotion
but I don't think I've heard
sorry I'm sorry Mr
chair um I am an individual citizen of
New Hampshire and I am here to voice
support for
cacr I strongly believe that decisions
regarding abortion should be solely left
to a pregnant person and their physici
this personal medical decision should
not be legislated it should be left to
individuals and
professionals legislators do not
understand all of the complications that
may occur during pregnancy and should
not be excuse me should not be
legislating it as a result until
abortion is ingrained in our
constitution current and future pregnant
persons are at risk even those who may
never choose to have an
abortion because they may not be able to
find adequate obstetric care if these
Obstetricians choose to not practice in
New Hampshire because of this issue I
think that is a really grave concern and
very realistic we may be seeing
that these unintended consequences could
be catastrophic for New Hampshire
citizens having given birth after a
full-term
pregnancy I can't imagine learning that
my fetus wasn't viable at 25 or 26 weeks
and yet still having to carry that fetus
full term the emotional scarring would
be catastrophic in my
opinion being pregnant is extremely
difficult even that I had a very easy
pregnancy and I'll tell you it was still
extremely emotional and extremely
physical
challenging I think these decisions
should be left to individuals and
absolutely needs to be in our
constitution thank you thank you man
questions to this
witness seeing none thank you uh next uh
Kenneth
berum thank
much and you did a pretty good job on my
name most people don't pronounce it
correctly
bero I'm sorry that's okay I've been
going through it since uh
kindergarten
um I live in Manchester I'm a doctor of
Chiropractic um I'm opposed to cacr
23 uh although I'm not an obstetrician
I've had uh many courses in embryology
obstetrics
Gynecology
Pediatrics um let me just talk about my
my former teacher who was uh
gynecolog she taught us Gynecology and
obstetrics she was a nurse and a midwife
at the
time when she was telling us this story
that she was uh delivering babies down
the hall in the hospital and then down
the hall she was aiding and killing them
it was very emotional for her so she
stopped doing
that um I can't speak for being pregnant
or having an abortion but several
members of my family have had
abortions and I
can relate as a man to the trauma and
the and the difficulty of unplanned
pregnancy
um these gentlemen have talked about and
people have talked about
viability of um and even when life
begins
um I have some things on the paper there
that
[Music]
um bernon Nathan sin was a uh he passed
away he was a a gynecologist who
performed over 75,000 abortions in his
lifetime he
um saw an ultrasound this was back in
the 80s of an abortion and this was
in the technology of 40 years ago where
the technology now if you look at a an
ultrasound of a baby in the womb even
very very small and early development
it's very graphic that is a person there
it is a
baby
um we this talk
about it's part of or it's a woman's
right to choose or control choice of her
body the baby in her womb is totally
different from
her she had the baby has totally
different DNA than the mother especially
if it's boy it's totally
different fetus is just a name that we
Des um telling us how old the child is
like toddler middle schooler teenager
and
adult tell us how old the person
is and because we can't see with our
Naked
initially in the womb it's similar to
and I have on the the paper
there with taking a picture of this
beautiful rainbow I saw it three times
coming up from Manchester three
different places beautiful rainbow
remember the old Polaroids or they still
have Polaroids you take a
picture the paper comes out you can't
see anything because it's
not fully developed yet but it's there
if I went up to you and I ripped it up
the picture you took of that
rainbow you'd you'd be very mad at me
for doing that because you took a
rainbow but it's not developed yet if
you give it time it will develop and
you'll see the
picture sir you're getting you're really
at the three minute point so I would
appreciate if you could just sum up what
you have to say Okay that Bernard naen I
mentioned after he performed those
75,000 abortions he made that video of
an actual
abortion an ultrasound and he stopped
performing abortions after that the
doctor who performed that
abortion had performed about 10,000
abortions previous to that he stopped
performing abortions because he saw that
it was a life in there the lady who was
assisting that yeah I really need you to
sum up Sir okay um you're you're
considerably over your time now I'm just
done here abortion is not safe many
women die I encourage you as a society
as legislators as
people Stop The
Killing all right questions for this
witness yes representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I really have a
question um for you some of our
Witnesses have been very generous and
have submitted to US Written testimony
which we in fact all read do you think
you could suggest that if someone is
going to submit written testimony that
they don't then stand up and read it but
perhaps just summarize it for us and for
the rest of the people in the room thank
you no I I I agree I think that I think
that is an excellent suggestion and I
would encourage future witnesses to
please please do that if you have
written testimony we uh you you
obviously we will take it and we will
read it and you can also submit that
online you should know if you if you
wish to but thank you good suggestion
thank you very much sir all right next
zazano good morning chn and honorable
house Judiciary Committee members my
name is Emily Zano I'm a resident of
exitor and I'm asking you to support
cacr
23 I am a pediatric emergency medicine
physician my adult life has been
dedicated to saving children's lives but
I could not save my own daughters I had
two abortions my story is of my love and
my heartbreak but the value is in my
body and my choices this was my first
pregnancy and very much wanted by my
husband and I we were shocked and
thrilled when our first scan at 12 weeks
showed two babies however the ultrasound
showed I also had an a uterine anomaly
a potentially life-threatening condition
the Twins were in two different areas of
my
uterus more studies suggested I was safe
and we would have our baby girls we
chose names I marked the date on my
calendar when they would be 29 weeks and
likely to survive at 16 weeks and 4 days
pregnant I woke up with pain that became
sharp and severe it hurt to breathe I
was ultimately sent to a Boston hospital
my husband and I sat in a dark room
where monitor show the ultrasound images
turned on during happy scans turned off
during the sad ones they were off for
ours the news was worse than we could
imagine the left side was a previously
unrecognized rudimentary horn and the
uterine wall had ruptured in two places
this fetus had no chance my womb was
literally broken on the right side the
baby had a congenital heart defect which
would require surgery and functioning
lungs to survive
if she could make it to viability in my
broken womb these findings changed
everything to save my life I needed
surgery and one of my daughters inside
needed to be removed in surgery they
saved the unicorni uterus and the fetus
on the right was still there but it was
clear that allowing the pregnancy to
continue would put me at a huge risk for
2 weeks I sat on the couch tried to heal
from surgery and I loved my baby as hard
as I could I
grieved we went to Boston for the
appointment the day before the DNC the
abortion we were there for medical care
we were there to save my life we were
there because this was the most
appropriate decision for our family we
were there because we needed to be there
my abortions saved my life my abortions
allowed me to have more children my
abortions allowed me to continue my work
to save your children's lives as a
doctor and as a patient I understand
just how different every pregnancy is
granite Staters and their medical
providers need all options available to
them without government
interference please pass cacr
23 allow voters to weigh in and protect
access to safe and legal abortion for
everyone who needs this Care thank you
for your time and for your service thank
you questions for this
Witness representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question I'm going to ask the same thing
do you have a reason why you feel 24
weeks is the appropriate time for this
Constitutional Amendment so I was not I
am not involved in the writing of this
constitutional amendment I am here to
support the Constitutional Amendment and
that voter should weigh in on the
Constitutional
Amendment other questions for this we
seeing none thank you very much next I'm
foisey good morning chair Lin and
honorable house Judiciary Committee
members my name is Michelle silly foise
I live in Temple and I am urging you to
support
ca23 2 years years ago I stood before
New Hampshire lawmakers for the first
time and told my daughter Kayla's story
our abortion story I was here to support
HB 1609 to add a fatal fetal diagnosis
exception to our state's abortion ban I
spoke of being a mother of seven
children including my daughter Kayla who
I lost 19 years ago due to a fatal fetal
anomaly our abortion was at 22 weeks
heading in for our routine ultrasound at
21 weeks we were filled with joy and
excitement for the new addition to our
family our 2 and 1/2-year-old was with
us that day and thrilled about becoming
a big sister we did not receive good
news on that day December 5th 2005 on
December 10th KLA was delivered
stillborn after our termination the day
before as we held her in our arms for
several hours we said goodbye to the
little girl that we continue to love
with all of our hearts and will for a
lifetime Kayla was found to have a
deletion in her 15th chromosome that was
not detected until after our abortion
our amniocentesis results returned a
month after our termination when I would
have been 6 weeks pregnant this timeline
is the reason that I began to tell our
story in support of the Fatal fetal
anomaly Amendment added to the abortion
ban instituted two years ago it is clear
that in these incredible complex
situations decision should be left to a
pregnant person and their doctor I have
learned a great deal over the course of
the last two years I have heard other
Granite Staters abortion stories our
experiences are varied but every one of
us deserve the right to make our own
personal private healthcare decisions
that's why I am urging you to allow
voters the opportunity to add the right
to abortion to our state
constitution since roie Wade was
overturned in summer of 22 our country's
reproductive healthc care landscape has
been in disarray one in three American
women have lost the right to abortion in
their home state while abortion remains
safe and legal in New Hampshire before
24 weeks we are the only state in New
England without a proactive protection
for abortion rights Granite Staters are
now susceptible to out of state attacks
on their Healthcare in New Hampshire we
won't don't let other states dict
dictate our rights that's not the 603
way I did not make the decision to have
an abortion with ease nor uninformed
though we had only hours to make our
decision those hours were filled with
gathering information and asking many
questions in the days that followed I
continued to look for answers and
together with my Physicians we made the
best decision for our family not once
did I look to my state legislators for
advice opinions or medical knowledge I
trusted in my Physicians expertise and
the information that we had Granite
Staters are capable of making thoughtful
decisions about their own Healthcare and
consultation with their loved ones faith
and medical providers as they see fit
New Hampshire's elected officials should
not turn their backs on our state's
tradition of trusting Granite Staters to
make these decisions in the face of
national uncertainty you have the
ability to take proactive action to
ensure abortions remain safe and legal
in New Hampshire I urge you to support
time
all set okay yeah I'll be quick Judge
Lynn good morning honorable committee
members in house
Judiciary my name is Brian I'm a
resident of conquered and I'm here
speaking in support of cacr 23 I'm also
speaking only for myself I merely want
to tell a quick story about my
experience supporting a loved one
through their abortion we struggled at
the time having grown up in a faith that
taught me to believe abortion abortion
was selfish and harmful I know now
firmly that abortion is Healthcare and I
decided that I wanted to be as
supportive as I could knowing that it
was her
decision in 2003 my then pregnant
girlfriend told me her decision to have
an abortion on the day the appointment I
remember quietly moving through a large
group of protesters with rosaries as we
walked up the steps to the equality
Health Center together right down the
street once we made it through the front
doors we immediately greeted and treated
with compassion and empathy the staff
there welcomed us with kindness and
without judgment with my partner's
permission the staff allowed me to go
upstairs and hold her hand during the
abortion my experience there felt like a
comforting Embrace with people who
listened understood and took care of us
with respect and
dignity I'll will never forget the
feeling and safety they created in that
room
ultimately we broke up that year however
we met for lunch 17 years later while
the decision for her was a challenging
one at the time we agreed that it was
the Draconian beliefs and cold talous
teachings we were brought up with that
made the experience of a medical
decision a living hell I used to have
nightmares of that day we went through
with the abortion I think about the
protesters and the shame put upon us
both in her decision now I dream of a
day where everyone can access the care
they need when they need it free from
shame judgment and harm without
government
intrusion as a man raising an
independent little girl it frightens me
that any politician or person in a
position of power thinks they should be
able to decide what a person does or
doesn't do with their body over the last
few years I have watched as a veracity
of attacks on abortion access escalate
in my state
I believe people should be supported in
their decisions and not be judged cacr
23 would amend the new hampster
Constitution and enshrine the right to
reproductive Freedom recognizing
individuals have the right to make
decisions about their own bodies and
reproductive choices after all
everyone's path in life looks a little
different access to abortion care is
essential for Equity autonomy and the
ability to determine our own lives none
of us can be truly free if we
don't all have the right to make our
decisions about our bodies our lives and
our futures uh Judge Lynn I'm I'm Irish
and I was baptized Catholic due to the
mismanagement from the dicese of
Manchester of their Predator
priest my innocence and right to choose
what happened to my body was stolen from
me as an alter
boy if Bishop leasy thinks I'll abide
him advocating for the flock to vote to
take away my little girl's right to
autonomy over her body he's dead wrong
okay um I'm here today to give a
testimony from my friend Marina kers of
Kensington New Hampshire um she couldn't
be here because of flooding at her
home good morning members of the New
Hampshire house Judiciary Committee I
oppose cacr 23 because I believe no one
sh should have the right to deprive an
emerging human being of Life sanctity of
life is not only a religious belief but
a moral and ethical conv conviction for
Millions even billions of people
worldwide it can't be erased from Human
Consciousness but is an often
rationalized way for the sake of
expediency pro-choice I'm all for that
too but only before conception not
after my personal experience at a young
age dictates my current pro-life stance
I can give faces and names to this issue
at age 17 before abortion was legal I
was pregnant out of we wedlock had it
been legal and left to my own devices
misgivings about the future might have
led me down a path of expediency via
abortion rather than a path of conscious
conscience and
integrity fortunately it wasn't legal
and it was also out of my hands my
parents subjected strongly to the idea
of abortion while being supportive of me
I surrendered my daughter for adoption
and later decided to have no other
children and more than two decades later
my daughter Crystal contacted me when I
met her and her husband they had two
daughters Cassie and Katie by this time
Cassie has two children Logan and Luna
now aged six and four those five people
are the face the name and the Beating
Heart of my pro-life conviction today a
decision for life always leads to
Greater Life not only that but my future
turned out fine too and my conscience is
clear to all women I say whatever our
personal decisions in the past we can
reclaim and stand up for our unique
position as the bearers and Defenders of
human life a position so important so
fundamental yet often devalued because
it can't be monetized nothing devalues
it more than the practice of abortion
men you are not letting us down and
depriving us of gender rights by being
pro-life thanks guys but the ability to
bear and protect life is precisely our
strength and privilege pass laws instead
to help women and children Thrive a
pro-life party doesn't exist in the US
the Democratic party supports the right
to life to end life before birth the
Republican Party supports the
proliferation of firearms so as to end
the lives of those who survive birth for
over four decades I was a registered
Democrat that changed about 15 years ago
due to the increasingly fanatical
pro-abortion Zeal under the guise of
women's Reproductive Rights respect for
Life put me outside the pale the
estimate is that at least 33% of
thanks and I have testimony for myself
as
well yeah I I'll I'll hand in both of
the
testimony I'm sorry I'm going to call on
Paul gaso
please and U members of the committee
I'm aware of the time if if there are
some of you if there are some of you who
want to uh break to get something to eat
I'm going to hang in here and maybe when
when you come back I might uh if we're
still going on I might break to have
something to eat but uh don't hesitate
to to uh get something to eat if you
want to Mr
gassa uh good afternoon uh committee uh
thank you for giving me the the
opportunity to speak in opposition uh to
this abortion Bill I've got three uh
specific things that I wanted to
communicate to you and I'm going to try
to do it within three minutes the first
is uh I am a sidewalk advocate for life
I've been doing this for over 10 years
I've talked to hundreds of women that
were entering uh Planned Parenthood and
other abortion facilities I've also
spoken to uh as many if not more of the
girls and the women coming out Planned
Parenthood uh part of our team uh
comprises uh two women that had
abortions one in their late teens and
the other in the early 20s both suffer
from
depression one uh indicates that she
hasn't been able to work she's 52 years
old she has government assistance she
has mental uh Health Care uh the other
is um trying to do what she can to help
other women she runs a support group she
says if she doesn't have her support
group weekly she's like an alcoholic
without AA these are two devastated
individuals uh another example of a
woman that's gone from being uh oh by
the way those two were initially
pro-choice since their abortions they
became pro-life another example of the
person making the same kind of tradition
is someone that many of you know her
name is Abby Johnson let me just read
this very quickly years ago Johnson
volunteered at a planed Parenthood
eventually became the director of the
clinic over eight-year career in the
industry she helped facilitate more than
22,000 abortions I really didn't even
know how I got to that point she said it
just happened in the blink of an eye uh
her transition to pro-life advocacy
started when she assisted with an
ultrasound guided abortion procedure at
13 weeks the pre-born baby had every
bodily function and Anatomy as a fully
grown adult for the first time I
witnessed the true nature of the work
that she was involved in and the unborn
baby suffering at the hands of a suction
tube I knew in that moment that what I
saw in just those few seconds wasn't a
choice it wasn't reproductive Justice it
was not justice of any kind it was
certainly not healthc care I knew that
what I witnessed in those moments was
murder murder murder of an innocent
human being in the womb and I knew I
could not participate in that
anymore the last point I want to make is
another item here
online uh this uh this came from the
baby body parts crisis uh this is from
uh Dr westoff from planned parenting and
I'm just going to read her quotes we've
just been working with people who want
particular tissues like you know they
want cardiac or they want eyes or they
want something else sir you're at the uh
the three you if there are quotes that
you want to yeah I understand sir just I
30 seconds please uh certainly
everything we provide oh gonads oh my
God gonads everything we provide is
fresh obviously we would have the
potential for a huge PR issue if this
information was shared
publicly so I tried to uh provide to
this committee three scenarios from a
prolife perspective I believe the
arguments from my side are more
representative of the true reality of
abortion uh than the emotional
experiences which I totally respect from
people that have had abortions I'm happy
to take questions thank you questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
uh thank you right uh uh sopie
Maro
please hello uh good afternoon and thank
you to the members of the committee very
much uh for your service and for your
time today um my name is Sophie Maro I'm
from Portsmouth and I'm really glad to
be here today to support cacr 23 um I'm
here representing myself but I do
volunteer with the lover ring Health
Center and with the reproductive Freedom
fund of New Hampshire um and in those
roles I support abortion patients before
during and after their appointments
whether that is coordinating a ride
helping them to access funding holding
their hand providing emotional support
um whatever it may be I consider it an
honor to support people in this way and
I'm really proud uh to do it um and it
is from this experience then that I say
that everyone's reason for having an
abortion is different everyone's reason
is valid um and everyone's reason is
private and personal to them and never
has anyone told me that they wish that
their State Rep could have been more
involved in that
decision um there is no place for the
government in someone's reproductive
decisions except to guarantee that that
person has the freedom to make those
decisions um the government does not
belong in my doctor's office or in my
private medical decisions um because I
can't participate equally in society if
somebody else gets to make those choices
for me I am not free to direct my life
if I don't get to be the one that has
the final say over my own health and
well-being and importantly I am not safe
if somebody else gets to decide what
happens to my body so just to wrap up uh
later today we'll hear about uh house
bills 1248 and
1541 um both of which are proof of why
we need to pass c23
um those bills reflect policies that are
deeply deeply
unpopular um as things that can kill you
generally tend to be um because that's
the bottom line is that abortion bans
kill and those bills are dangerous um
and we need to stop wasting time on them
we need to stop wasting resources on
them and bills like them um and we do
that by deciding collectively to protect
abortion in our constitution the dos
ruling put the onus on us to make that
decision um so please let us make that
decision thank you for your time thank
you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
please thank you for hearing my
testimony chair Lyn and members of the
House Judiciary Committee so I'm here to
oppose cacr 23 and the reason why I
oppose it is because I believe in the
sanctity the sacredness of all human
life from conception to Natural death in
our US Constitution now I'm a
constituent of New Hampshire but we're
part of the United States of America and
in our US Constitution it says we hold
these truths to be self-evident that we
are endowed by our creator with certain
inalienable rights that among those are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness you can't have Liberty and you
can't have the pursuit of happiness if
you don't have life first now abortion
bills have a very flawed premise or
abortion rights have a very flawed
premise that they are based on because
they're trying to say that a life is not
valid unless it reaches a certain stage
of gestation could be birth it could be
24 weeks whatever it is but it's not a
valid life and it's also a statement the
second premise that's flawed is that we
Define life as being worthwhile to have
freedom and to have the ability to
pursue happiness if we decide that
they're wanted so you have a baby that's
not wanted their life is disposable now
back in Nazi Germany Adolf Hitler and
the Nazi regime they worked very hard
for years perhaps even decades to start
devaluing human life to their people so
finally they got to the point where they
could encourage the people that we don't
want a certain class of people in that
situation it was the Jews and so we are
justified in killing 6 million of them
now this is a very slippery slope that
we're going down as a society and have
we really stooped to that level that we
devalue life so much do we want New
Hampshire to be a culture of life or a
culture of death and I just heard a
testimony a few minutes ago saying that
um you have to fight for life and that
banning abortions deprives life I think
abortions deprived life the mother who
makes a decision to abort her baby is
not deprived of Life the baby in her
womb is the only one that is killed so I
think of you know we were told back in
73 when roie Wade was passed this is not
going to lead to any more death it's
just abortion it's just about the baby
in the womb that the mother's not ready
to have but we have the Terry shyo case
and she was a disabled woman and her
husband said she wouldn't want to live
disabled like this so he made the
decision the court agreed with him for
her to be euthanized by withholding food
now the thing is she had no living will
no one was there in the conversation
between her and her husband we don't
know if she actually said that so this
is a very very slippery slope that we're
going down as a society and we have the
opportunity to agree with the Supreme
Court of the United States and stand for
life as they ruled Roby weade
overturning was a good thing and we have
a chance even if we're one in a handful
of States in this country that stands
for life we can stand for what's just
and true and we can stand for you're
over your 3 minutes and if you just sum
up I'd appreciate it okay so the bottom
line is I believe that all life should
be protected from conception to Natural
death and thank you very much for
hearing my testimony thank you questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you m uh next
Deni
thank you chairman um Roy Den from
Windham um I represent uh the Nisa
Columbus I'm the state life director for
the nice of Columbus which represents
about 7,000 members here in the state of
New Hampshire along with your
families and um I'll just take a minute
I'm not going to take more than that um
biological facts every U um every
study's ever ever been done um been done
um human life begins a conception we all
know that that's a fact and after 8
weeks after conception the baby's heart
beat is detected and the baby feels
pain
and every survey uh which was mentioned
here earlier every survey Across America
um particularly the Harvard Harris poll
that 90% of all voters across the
country oppose abortion right up to the
moment of birth and 70% of independent
voters oppose abortion right up to
birth so that relates to in New
Hampshire that remate relates that 10 to
a maximum of 30 30% of the voters here
in the granite state support late term
abortions right up to the moment of
birth
this is Extreme this is radical and this
is poor legislation for the State of New
Hampshire I have I appeal to every
member here uh of this Judiciary
Committee to consider what we're doing
here we're talking about protecting
human life or we're not protecting human
life and I I urge everyone to change
your minds and hearts and consider
protecting The Unborn Child in the
mother's womb thank you thank you Mr Den
uh questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call
on I know I'm going to butcher this name
Beverly
piix if if I pronounce that incorrectly
please correct me thank you and thank
you for can you hear me
okay Beverly pety from loud New
Hampshire um my testimony is really for
this
afternoon but I just want the committee
to know what I've been going through
this morning sitting
here um I you
know I suffer from a little
post-traumatic
stress um disorder and I have a history
I'm I'm a woman and uh the testimonies
that I've heard today have been very
varied so we've heard heard a lot of
different
stories uh every
situation that involves bringing a new
person into this world is
unique and that's why I feel like it
doesn't really belong with the Judiciary
commit the Judiciary Committee and I
will be here this afternoon to testify
on the other bill because really this
comes down
to uh our first amendment rights to
exercise our own
beliefs and so some people here believe
that life starts at conception and maybe
it does I'm not really saying that it
doesn't it could actually start at
conception maybe it does that's up for
the
scientists
but uh the sanctity of my
conception I I have God has given me
life and I'm grateful for the life that
I've been
given but I also believe that I have the
right over my own body and my own
decisions and I've had to make those
decisions in my life I've been on both
ends of the
Spectrum in my life I've had to make
decisions to make abortions I've had
decisions to keep my child and I have
lost a child at 16 weeks and none of
that belongs none of those decisions
government belongs with me and my
relationship to
God right thank you my belief my belief
and my religion and we have freedom of
religion and every other testimony here
when it comes to right of Life deals
with
God and we have the the right to
religion first okay so it is up to the
woman and I I think this uh vote is for
the protection of women because it
involves medical
personnel and the medical personnel
still needs to be involved in the care
and protection of a woman you can't just
say that all life is sanct is Sanctified
when you hear the testimony of a woman
who almost lost her life because uh she
and she needed a DNC for that right so
if you say if you make a decision like
that you're putting other women's life
at risk and that's not your decision
that's not your decision you're also
making the
decision to murder live women women who
are already alive on this planet doing
things like taking care of other
children she's a doctor and her life was
at risk she takes care she's a medical
Prof professional we need to have
respect for the people in our society to
do the jobs that they need to do and
give that responsibility to our medical
personnel and I'm here talking now but I
am going to be here this afternoon uh
because I wouldn't be here now if it
wasn't for those bills that you have
this afternoon and I'm a little bit
confused as to why you have those bills
this afternoon and you have this bill
this bill should be brought up to the
population of the state of New Hampshire
to be voted on because it is ultimately
the people's that's why that's the
definition of a democracy is for us to
be able to vote on these things not for
a Judiciary Committee to make those
decisions so I do hope it goes up for
vote and whatever these other bills are
this afternoon I'm going to get up and
you're going to hear the same thing
except that it's going to be in written
testimony and you're you know I I really
think that we have precedent here in the
United States Constitution and the New
Hampshire Constitution that protects a
woman's right to make this decision for
herself so thank you thank
you um lastly uh I'm going to call uh
the last card I have is for Devin Quinn
kin
Quinn um chair lenon and representative
yeah uh members of the committee my name
is Devin Quinn I'm the director of
policy for the New Hampshire women's
foundation and we are very uh proud to
support cacr 23 uh because uh the right
to access the full range of reproductive
health care including abortion is
crucial to women's health and economic
security and has long-term impacts on
women and their families uh New
Hampshire is the only state in New
England that has not proactively
protected the right to abortion uh in
state law uh despite New Hampshire women
from across the political Spectrum uh
fighting for decades for the right to
reproductive Freedom uh it's time to
allow New Hampshire voters to decide if
there should be a clear and affirming
right to bodily autonomy in the state's
Constitution not only is the choice to
end a pregnancy a right but it is for
some a means to economic Prosperity
safety and the ability to flee violence
and the opportunity to pursue dreams and
develop thriving communities New
Hampshire women are more likely than men
to live in poverty with a gender wage
Gap that increases by race ethnicity and
geography and they are likely uh and
women are more likely to have been
impacted by interpersonal or sexual
violence these indicators of well-being
are significantly impacted by the
ability to make reproductive decisions
including abortion for oneself we must
prot protect the right to abortion to
continue to support women's autonomy
Health Wellness Economic Security and
ability support thriving
communities happy taking questions thank
you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
um I don't have any other uh Pink cards
is there anyone else who wishes to
23 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on cacr 23 thank you all for
being here um and I'm going to uh recess
the committee until
1:30 uh when we will take up uh HB
1248 um and
um I'm hoping that the cafeteria
downstairs isn't going to be overly
crowded but if it is and we are a little
bit late please understand that we will
continue as soon as we as soon as we get
you
everyone um it's a little past 1:30 I'm
sorry we were back a little bit late but
uh we tried our best uh and I'm now
going to open uh the house Judiciary
Comm Committee hearing on uh hb1
1248 uh FN relative to uh restrictions
on access to abortion and I'm going to
first recognize representative uh Dave
t
you just said I'm Dave testerman I'm a
representative from Franklin uh I I
represent the city of Franklin uh today
I'm going to in I I came to introduce
the bill 1248 it's fairly simple it just
takes the uh the the time for number of
weeks kicks it down from 24 to 15 uh and
as a uh uh
a uh an extra doctor to the
proceedings that's it thank you all
right thank you questions for
representative
t Okay seeing none thank you very
much
okay um next I'm going to call on
please uh thank you Mr chair good
afternoon committee uh represented John
solz Grafton district 18 I am a
co-sponsor of this bill and
um I'm actually proud of co-sponsoring
this Bill yes it's 15 days this is the
15-day bill right correct it's a 15-day
Bill thank you um I just want to bring
up a few things that I brought up even
this morning and and we talked about the
uh cacr bill but in essence we're still
talking about a life of a child a baby
at this point and it's not going away
all right we're not trying we're trying
to protect life and save life where the
other side or the sponsors or or the
people against this bill are trying to
actually destroy life and kill it and
it's not a
growth you know it's not a uh a tumor
you know it's an individual being I mean
from once that when that once the the
woman and the man get together and they
do the ACT IM and that uh uh that seed
actually penetrates the egg it is
immediately starting to be a unique
human being you're talking about hair
color eye color skin color height maybe
even weight um and anything else that
goes along with the body at that point
so I mean this is very interesting I
mean it's not like science we can't
create this stuff and I don't understand
why we're trying to destroy it it makes
no sense to destroy it so I just want to
bring up a few items here that I that I
had gotten written down here you know we
I heard even this morning it's like my
body my choice and and God I mean I keep
hearing it over and over and over my
body my choice you know isn't that the
time of choice wouldn't that be the time
when you're actually having the sex
taking the sex doing the sex I mean
seriously isn't it isn't that the time
you you know you make the choice of
saying should I protect myself or
not what about at that point after
they've had the sex at that point the
child that starts to grow immediately
what about the she's a woman it could be
a woman or it could be a man but let's
assume she's a woman what about her
choice what about her rights you know
it's like you're you're only protecting
the living outside because you can
physically see a person but just because
you can't physically see someone doesn't
mean they're not
existing and and and again you you just
keep trying to kill this child over and
over and and it's it's just as
legislators we're
actually having license or we making the
law to say we have the right to murder
think about it we're creating the law
that says hey you can abort your child
right now it's 24 weeks 6
months we say you can go ahead and kill
your child you can murder your child at
that point up until 6 months we're the
lawmakers we have to determine that and
to say this is where we have to look at
morality and ter you know and say wait
you know where are we going as a
morality and people of New Hampshire you
know I have a document here that I got
from
U Americans United for life they did
some research for me which I appreciate
what they did and I'm I'm just going to
read a couple things and what I can do
is I'll send it to the entire committee
you you guys can look through it it's
about 63 pages and you know we we're
going to just rehash the same things
over and over this bill the first bill
the next bill at this point um but I
just want to kind of put on a couple
things which is you know you to start
thinking about these couple of things
they're
irritating says most abortions are done
social for social reasons not because
the baby or the mother is
medical then it goes on it says the gut
Institute has provided a number of
reports over two decades that have
identified the reasons why women choose
abortion and they have been consistently
reported that childbearing would
interfere with their education work and
ability to care for existing dependence
and so
on overall common exceptions to
abortions restrictions are estimated uh
to account for less than than 5% of all
abortions all right less than
5% meaning the 95% of abortions are
for um elective or unspecified reasons
95% this is what we're talking about I
mean the 5% yes if the woman needs the
help you know there's something going
wrong with her life and you know
something happened in your life yes I
get it you know save the woman for all M
you know all possibilities but you know
this here
95% we saying take that baby just throw
it in the trash can someone said we
should all go down to an abortion clinic
and watch one done I watch a video even
it be amazing you you you might change
your mind just by watching
that I'm just going to point out maybe
here if it goes on it
um it says it goes on the belief that a
woman needs abor the belief that a that
women need abortion in order to obtain
Su success and equality in American
society is unfounded and a um accurately
harms women basically this this goes on
to say
that
um women are harmed by abortions active
activist equality uh B uh arguing
because it easily communicates the
woman's pregnancy the woman's pregnancy
and parenting is a
disability it's not a disability it's a
blessing it truly is a
blessing and and it goes on last part of
this says uh um parent is a disability
it for most femal suff and most female
suffer therefore it explicitly or
implicitly assumes that the male body is
the and reproduction model is the Nom
you know it's not the case this I mean
we can just go over and over and over
and over you we all have to come to this
morality part of our life here and say
you know come on let's let's we all know
the truth all right there are some
abortions that absolutely need to happen
there are 95% of them that don't and we
can't be the ones given the license for
the law we got to stop this if it's 15
days 15 weeks we got to stop but
actually it should be from conception
and really I'll admit that 15 days is
technically from conception thank you
thank you questions for this
trip uh thank you for taking my question
uh I since you said that 95% of the
abortions are elective could do you have
any statistics on when in the pregnancy
these uh elective uh abortions occur say
at the 15-day Mark or the 15 week month
or the 24 week Mark uh it in this
article here it does not say which I am
going to pass the entire article on for
you and it's again it's only six R pages
and and they also reference all the
footnotes and where they have all their
information from all right so that does
not say if it was like from the first
week to you know the 27th week or
Witness none thank you very much thank
you Mr chair uh next I'm going to call
Phillips thank you um Mary hecken
Phillips representing Grafton County
District 12 I rise today in opposition
of hb1
1248 let's just say you ignore the
science that at 15 days it's difficult
to determine exact just age because
we're really talking about two to four
cells instead of a
fetus let's just ignore the fact that at
15 days nothing would show up at an
ultrasound and no diagnosis of a
mother's health or a baby's prospective
Health Care can be made Let's just
ignore the fact that at 15 days
Physicians can't knowingly locate let
alone perform any procedure on said 2 to
four
cells Let's ignore the fact that at days
um an abortion ban would further Drive
obgy surgeons and Physicians from
practice in New Hampshire creating a
pregnancy care and reproductive Cancer
Care desert for all of our
families let's just ignore that more
than 75% of granite Staters who believe
that reproductive Choice should be
available to pregnant
people Let's ignore the unfair Financial
impacts on women and pregnant people who
are denied abortion care aiming in dead
for underemployment and less than full
economic
progress Let's ignore the vast majority
of granite Staters who believe that
government should have no place in the
medical decision-making or interfering
with granite St Staters
privacy Let's ignore the other do
denominations of Christianity and
religion that believe abortion is moral
Humane and a true expression of God's
love and Let's ignore the fact that a
cruel 15-day abortion ban would
effectively be signing the death
warrants for granite Staters who
experience complications in pregnancy
and run out of time or cannot afford to
travel to other states to get the health
care that we need so let's just ignore
all that science logic fact reason
Humanity let's pass this unconscionable
Bill Let's be clear passage of hb1 1248
will accelerate the quickening pace of
the voting age electorate in New
Hampshire that runs not walks away from
the Republican party for either more
independent or more democratic
candidates who will protect independent
medical decisionmaking and the right to
reproductive healthc care Choice let
this be a warning to you a 15-day
abortion ban will trigger a generational
political wave against trusting
Republicans to draft public policy for
which the G GOP will never fully fully
recover in the state of New Hampshire
Passage of 1248 will be a strategic
failure and a colossal mistake and for
these reasons I implore members of this
committee to vote in expedient to
legislate thank you thank you questions
witness yes representative gon thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking our questions you said that
in 15 days there's only two to four
cells let alone a fetus so when is there
a fetus uh thank you for the question um
so I am not a healthc care physician I
am married to one and um I do not hold
the expertise to um to delineate when a
fetus becomes into existence but I think
we should recognize that at 15 days from
the point of pregnancy we are not
talking about a heartbeat we're not
talking about cardiac activity we're not
talking about hearts and lungs we're not
talking about hands and fingertips and
feet we're talking about two to four
cells so I think we just need to
recognize that you know that is not
something that a woman will even know
she's pregnant at that point because
there is no physical embodiment that
would cause a woman to know they're
pregnant at that point Thank you other
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next representative Perez did you wish
to
testify
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee um I was an original signer on
this bill I would like to read quickly
to you my um apology to my constituents
to my federal fed fellow um
legislators uh HB 1248 does not
represent my the voice of my
constituents I have withdrawn my name as
a co-sponsor when I was first approached
with the intent of this proposed bill I
was told that it would be offer it would
offer lowering the existing limit of 6
months 24 weeks without restrictions to
3.5 months 15 weeks without restrictions
for pregnancy termination when the draft
was released from the office of
legislative Services I did not do my due
diligence and neglected to review the
proposal prior to AG greeting to
co-sponsor this was my mistake I and
admittedly a grave one I trusted but did
not verify but this was not being
offered as an excuse I had heard from
multiple constituents that they felt a
15 week limit was more in line with what
they would be comfortable supporting
based on that and prior tentatively
agreeing to this bill I researched all
the pregnancy clinics in New Hampshire I
researched um in New Hampshire that
offered um that offer pregnancy
termination including Planned Parenthood
I found that medical abortions are only
offered up to 10 to 11 weeks with as an
aspiration or dilations are offered
between 13 and 15 week six days except
for Planned Parenthood which offers um
Pro aspirations from 14 to 16 and
dilation procedures up to 20 we one
weeks here in New Hampshire although I
am adamantly pro-life I have I have said
I have said since first announcing my
run for representative that I would not
have my Personal Agenda but instead be a
voice your voice that continues to be my
pledge I'm truly sorry that potentially
misrepresented misrepresented your voice
it was not my intention and therefore
please accept my
withdrawal I take full responsibility
that all being said I too like
representative patau found
that not one of the individuals that I
encountered during my run for office had
any idea of what the law was here in New
Hampshire they had no idea that we had a
six-month Li uh allowance for abortions
for any reason in the states I have
since I have since becoming elected had
multiple constituents reach out to the
state that 6 months is too long why that
is why I continually questioned in the
last hearing why 24 weeks um when I
explained to those not aware that they
were surprised that it was abortion was
allowed that high that is one of the
reasons when speaking about CR2 cacr I
kept asking the question I am prolife
but I was not elected to represent
myself I believe that the 24 weeks is
way too high the constituents want 15
weeks and people are so
uninformed about what the actual laws
are here in New Hampshire that we need
to guide them until they can become
informed thank you thank you uh
witness seeing none thank you um Heather
Stockwell
well I was going to say good morning but
it is afternoon uh good
afternoon while I'm unbelievably sad
that I need to be present at this New
Hampshire state house today I uh to
defend my individual rights I also
wouldn't want to be anywhere
else I am speaking today in support
still of cacr 23 which you heard this
morning and I had to leave um and
against HB 1541 and
1248 I've lived in the state for over 50
years and as some of you that are may be
sitting here today may have known my
father Steve Avery who was a Republican
state representative for approximately
house and during that time period which
was over 30 years ago close to 40 years
ago I had many fatherdaughter
conversations
with with him about this
topic because legis similar legislation
uh was also being heard at that time to
restrict access to this important piece
of health care which affects o around
population and it's amazing me to me
that we really even have anything left
to discuss but here we are so as you
know with that timeline I also grew up
in a time when when people were dying
because they were not able to find a
medically safe abortion place to have an
abortion many folks lost family members
I know families that lost family members
and mothers of families during this
time and so I understand the
repercussions about restricting abortion
access so during these discussions I
obviously shared stories I shared my own
story but I presented them as my friend
stories I also did share my friend
stories with my father who had struggled
with this topic and I managed to get my
father to see the other side quote
unquote of this issue to see that this
was a matter of individual rights
freedom and liberty to make decisions
about our own
bodies while I did not share that to
with my dad that some of these stories
were about me today I will gladly stand
here and tell you all that abortion
saved my life saved it and so while
we're talking about life and death and
human
beings I'm one of the people right and
women or people that can get pregnant
those are the people that we're talking
about who deserve to have rights
otherwise we are not full citizens
so the other part that saved my life is
the fact that I did not have to tell my
father about
this and I don't know if any of you
understand the repercussions of a young
person telling their parent who does not
agree with their decision what what
kinds of consequences can come of that
to I Knew other options were not going
to work for me
abortion adoption
while a great option for some people I
knew it would not work for me I knew I
would not be able to give birth to a
baby and then give it up for adoption I
already knew
that I also knew that I had not finished
College I had other goals in my life to
finish college to have a career and that
if I became pregnant and gave birth to
that child that I was more likely to
have to be on Public Assistance or
Services I was not going to have the
career I wanted because I was not going
to be able to finish school and I am not
lying as other I think someone else this
morning um said I'm not a liar that is
an actual truth that is the actual truth
and I'm standing here to tell you my
truth so for me that decision was fairly
simple but many folks folks who even
support having a choice may also
struggle with that decision for many
reasons whether it's an individual thing
or a group or family thing or a
spiritual thing or an economic thing
it's not always an easy cut and dry
decision as many folks seemingly would
like to portray people who have
abortions many pregnant people simply do
not know that that they are pregnant in
the early stages most discover I would
say around 30 days when their
menstration cycle has
failed to initiate for that month that
is generally when someone would seek a
pregnancy test or medical care so
restricting that right even by reducing
the amount of time that one can follow
through like getting appointments and
counseling would be a violation of the
United States con constitution in my
view by restricting a person's right to
bodily
autonomy now bily autonomy this is my
final piece bily autonomy is also at the
Cornerstone of medical ethics and I'm a
healthc care organizer for my profession
so I read a lot about Healthcare medical
ethics is really important to me and
it's the build it's one of the building
blocks literally of our freedom and our
Liberty we are free to refuse refuse
medical treatment if we choose we can
even get a second or even third opinion
and ultimately whatever decision we
make we get to either reap the rewards
or suffer the
consequences even if someone did not
agree with our choice it was ours to
make and I will just end on
otherwise we are not free in the state
of New Hampshire that proclaims that it
stands for these ideals or that we would
otherwise be better off
dead Live Free or Die death is not the
worst of evils we say
that I'm asking you to please protect
our rights our individual rights as
human
beings thank you so much for considering
my testimony today do you have have any
questions thank you very much questions
Stapleton thank you Mr chair and thank
question it's a complex issue it sure is
and there are a lot of uh nuances and
circumstances that have been discussed
here and uh earlier on in testimony yes
I was here this morning and
we can appreciate the hardship and the
struggle and the difficulty in making
choices but one of the things that I
haven't heard about is
when do we consider the life of the
nassin human being that's being formed
in the womb when does that individual
person have rights under the
Constitution and how do we balance that
with the personal decisions that you
just talked about
yeah I I I guess that is the con
conundrum for many
um I'm not sure I can answer that
question because it is so
um I'm not a doctor I'm not a um I
consider myself maybe a philosopher uh
but I personally believe that it's birth
it is birth while it is a living being
we don't actually consider them a human
being don't get a Social Security number
they don't get any health you know the
mother is getting the healthc care not
necessarily the baby at that point until
we're really in the last trimester I
would say that's my understanding I I
will stand here today and tell you I am
the mother of a 22-year-old son and so I
I know both sides of this and I did I I
had my son when I was ready to have a
family when I had a more secure life
where I was married and I
was had a house to live in a lot of my
life when I was younger was not so
stable and I didn't think it would be
fair to bring a life into the world as
it is without being having the capacity
or the means to take care of that child
and even when one is adopted that also
means that they are receiving some sort
of services right they're in some kind
of um institution if you will or program
for children who do not have families
and so it's still a burden if you will
on our
services either way so I don't I I guess
it's not really the the whole point I
guess is
because frankly it's it's it's happening
in my body right or a woman's body
somebody that has a uterus let's just
say that right right other questions for
this
witness followup yes yeah thank
you so it's got to be a difficult
decision sure for each individual as to
when the value of that life in the
womb deserves to be sure born or
otherwise
CC but what I'm getting at here is the
job that the legislators have to do is
to set some guidelines and we did that
with the fetal Life protection act and
we're talking about is it uh 15 days 15
weeks 18 weeks 24 weeks um Planned
Parenthood versus Casey uh focused on
the viability when when um a a life in
the womb could conceivably live outside
on its own sure I mean these are guide
posts sure but and they may be different
for each each person I think you're
you're asking me a question that is not
in my expertise and I'm not a doctor and
I don't claim to be one on
TV um that was humor by the way
um and I think what you
are which you're you're you're getting
at that timeline and restricting that
timeline knowing what I know about how
hard it is to to have access to health
care right now especially in our state
because we have had a hard time
retaining
doctors I've literally gone out of state
to receive health care because I can get
it faster in Massachusetts than I can in
New
Hampshire the weight time was
significantly less and so
with that said that those decisions are
very complicated we should give people
the time they need and deserve to make
that difficult decision and not rush
them doctors are going to have their own
opinions because they know more about
the human body they may have other
recommendations but that is all between
a person an individual and their doctor
and their family and whoever they have
in their Circle it is not the business
of legislators to restrict our rights
this has been a medical procedure for a
long time now we just want to keep it
safe and
accessible whether you agree with that
or not whether you want to have an
abortion or not is nobody's business but
I'm here to tell you I'm out here I
don't really want to come here and tell
you about the fact that I've had an
abortion but I'm here today because it
was an important decision in my life and
I still feel that I made the right
decision for
me would I make the same decision now or
when I was of childbearing age no maybe
not I might have had a different
decision was my fetus viable these are
all like what if questions and it's
still those conversations belong between
the pregnant person and their providers
right not the legislator not the
government is there any other other
questions to this
trip uh thank you for taking my question
uh you mentioned that
uh the delay to receive Health Care in
New Hampshire was
uh causing a problem and that you
essentially had to go to Massachusetts
to get your health care could you please
tell me what kind of Health Care you
were
getting I would prefer
not thank you uh I will just say that it
was a six-month weight in New Hampshire
and it was a two-month weight in
Massachusetts that was the difference
that was that's a pretty significant
difference when you might be navigating
surgery perhaps so yeah it was
significant other questions to this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you so much for your time I
appreciate thank you uh Liz Canada
please and I I again I'm I'm trying to
be mindful of the time I'm going to ask
you the the following the witnesses to
please try to limit your testimony to 3
minutes if you would please we'll do
thank you thank you Mr chairman so again
for the record my name is Liz Canada I'm
the advocacy director director for
Planned Parenthood New Hampshire action
fund Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England we're in strong opposition to
House Bill 1248 it's a complete ban on
abortion in New Hampshire 15 days which
is the subject of this bill is before
almost anyone could even know they are
pregnant and before pregnancy tests are
even accurate so I want to use my time
and I'll keep it within my two minutes I
promise to explain how pregnancy works
as a reminder to this committee
pregnancy is counted from the first day
of your period so day one is the first
day of your period around day 8 or 9
after your period has ended it is
possible to get
pregnant around day 14 is ovulation when
a person is most likely to get pregnant
within 24 to 48 hours of ovulation a
sperm can fertilize an egg and then the
egg needs to to be implanted into the
uterus and now in this timeline that
I've just given you we are either at or
after day 15 which is what this bill is
about and when abortion would be banned
this bill is absolutely outrageous it's
one of the most restrictive abortion
bands in the country it would put us on
par with Texas and Arkansas and Alabama
and these other states where women and
Pregnant patients are having to travel
out of state out of their home state to
get the care that they need and under no
circumstances should we in New Hampshire
be trying to emulate what is happening
in those other states so we urge you to
vote in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 1248 thank you thank you questions
witness seeing none thank you um next
I'm going to call on uh uh car Kenne
Reed
thank you so much for uh your time
hearing my testimony in strong
opposition to hp1
1248 uh my name is Courtney Reid I am
policy Advocate at the ACLU of New
Hampshire uh I will keep it brief for
you as you uh have gotten a copy of my
written testimony um what this bill does
uh is essentially an allout abortion ban
in the state of New
Hampshire uh Banning people from making
a decision about their Healthcare before
they would even know that they're
pregnant um decisions like this don't
only infringe on the right to privacy
and undermine uh individual's autonomy
and making private decisions about um
the trajectory of their life course but
they also have um and what you've heard
in previous testimony um really damaging
Public Health
consequences um when we've seen other
abortion bans in some states for example
a six- we ban in Texas there have been
um
correlating uh effects in public health
for example like I mentioned in Texas an
11.5% increase in deaths since the onset
of the D of the ban with experts
agreeing that the legislation has
increased health risks for both babies
and mothers Granite Staters need access
to reproductive care um and this bill
would make it nearly impossible for them
to access it in the state I urge members
of the committee to vote decisively
against this Bill thank you thank you
witness say thank you very much next uh
pritzer is that right is there another
Beverly from Lowden yeah yep all right I
would rather not be filmed do I have
that option not to be filmed maybe I
um I just concur with uh the testimony
of uh Heather Stockwell uh
a lot of what she had to say I could
definitely relate to but uh what I have
here is just what I could pick out from
the bill itself the first thing I picked
out was that it starts with in the year
of Our Lord which infers that a person
has to believe in the Lord in order to
comply with the law um I hope I have
time to read through this I'll try to
read it as quickly as possible because
really the Crux of it is at the end but
this bill deals with the biology of
women and therefore it belongs to the
Health and Human Services committee
to have it with the judicial Judiciary
Committee goes against the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution the Congress shall make no
law respecting establishment of religion
and honestly every argument in favor of
of uh the pro-life deals with life
starts at conception because uh I don't
exactly understand why we had testimony
here about pregnancies and and and how
pregnancies work can um I'm going to
just move on to the second the second is
the paragraph shall be construed to
require the performance of an ultra
sound only if the provider either knows
that the fetus has a gastation agent can
I just ask you to get a little closer to
the microphone I think we're having some
trouble it appears it appears okay there
are 22 weeks
or4 days between 15 days and 24 weeks
even I know that and I'm I'm not a
medical professional it appears to be
that this bill contains absolutely no
measure of compromise to the status of
the current legal terms for abortion
while 24 weeks may be a little too long
too close to viability 15 days is too
far from it in fact research shows that
most women are not aware that they have
missed a period or can even have a
period and have conceived and not know
it this is especially true of women who
work
women who are working miss a period
could easily attribute it to stress
which is a major contributor to a
woman's regularity and I do have uh I'm
going to give you these the research
that I found on about that it would be
in the best interest of all men and
women if distinctions of when to call
abortion a crime were left up to the
professionals who understand the nature
of these subtle biological nuances this
was the entire purpose of Row versus
Wade to give the authority to the
distinctions of whether a fetus was
viable or if the mother's life was in
danger to the medical professionals
leaving these decisions up to law
enforcement is
Impractical it totally infringes on the
privacy of even the union between a man
and a
woman it is even stated in our New
Hampshire constitutional Bill of Rights
under the Article 2 Section B right of
privacy
an individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion and private or
personal information is natural
essential and
inherent the fact that this bill is
founded on the religious belief that God
creates life is kind of a fantasy in my
opinion because what creates life is the
joining of an egg and a sperm from two
consenting adults God does not tell
people when to conceive when to even
have sex the premise that you would ban
abortion is the premise that that you
would have people performing sexual acts
only when they intend to have children
and that is totally not
realistic life does not start at
fertilization we've had that already
life is completely dependent on the
woman for it to achieve success outside
the body not the Judiciary Committee a
woman has religious freedom she can
choose whether or not to believe in God
she can choose to believe in God and get
an abortion she even if she believes in
God or she can believe in something or
nothing because we have freedom of
religion it doesn't matter because she
has the choice to pick her own beliefs
according to the US Constitution and the
New Hampshire Constitution it's not the
Judiciary
committee's decision for that if a fetus
could survive outside a woman's body
then she would not be human and that's
where you're taking this because women
are going to abstain from reproduction
if you start putting these kind of rules
on them uh I am a woman and I'm a human
and I believe in God God has save my
life and he will save the lives of many
women and many babies in into the
future it's a very small percentage of
women that are seeking abortions up to
full
term as somebody previously stated New
Hampshire abortion service centers have
restrictions already up to like 11 weeks
so this bill whoever introduced it was
really crossing the
boundaries of what is reasonable to
expect
um I believe that women can I ask you to
uh to summarize I've got one more
paragraph I believe that women are
divinely designed to determine whether
they can sustain another life or
not women who give birth to life every
day all over the world deserve to
maintain the respect and the reverence
for the sacrifices that they make to
keep humans in this world we do not have
a shortage of humans in this world this
we need to be able to respect women's
right to decide for themselves and thank
you for my listening to my testim thank
you questions to this
witness I taking questions you all right
winess does not want to take questions
please
hello there thanks for letting me speak
um my name is Dr Maris toand I'm an
obstetrician gynecologist in Southern
New Hampshire uh I think we've already
heard a lot of testimony I'm going to
try not to repeat anything that's
already been said um this is the most
restrictive ban it's more restrictive
than the ban in Texas um we know that
bans of this nature are very um have
poor consequences for the patients in
um sorry I'm not as eloquent as usual
today I worked last
night um so just to clarify a little bit
about the physiology of a menstrual
period I agree with what people have
said 15 days um is around the time that
Aver on average people will ovulate some
people ovulate after that so really at
this ban a decent percentage of um
people would not actually even be
pregnant
um so it would be impossible to perform
an abortion it also would be impossible
to tell if a patient is pregnant roughly
30 days is the very soonest that you can
tell a patient is pregnant based on a um
hormone test either through the urine or
blood um through an ultrasound you know
the earliest you can see something is
about five weeks sometimes six weeks uh
so you know really this doesn't make any
sense when it comes to um reproductive
physiology
in the grand scheme of things um you
know I I I think that we have great data
and has been very well eloquently put
today to show um the negative
ramifications of having very restrictive
abortion banss and that's not just on
patients that's also on your healthc
care provider um uh population um this
would push Healthcare Providers out of
the state it would also severely limit
the ability of healthcare providers in
the state to provide safe accessible
care in many situations we know that
abortion is an evidence-based essential
component of reproductive Health Care um
and to not have that option um puts
patients at significant risk thank you
witness see none thank you uh next uh
please good morning thank you for
letting me speak here
um got a couple things I strongly oppose
uh this bill I believe a woman really
needs to be able to make her own
decision with assistance from her
physician uh to push this to 15 days is
crazy as as it's been said multiple
times 15 days you don't even know you're
pregnant much less have enough time at
that point to really think about what to
do get a doctor's appointment to go
forward one way or the other so 15 days
is just absolutely crazy um the other
thing I noticed in this bill there's no
exceptions for rape or anything to that
effect um you know you we've seen what's
happened in other states here that's uh
passed abortion bills and all the people
are have to go out of state if they have
the means or they have to have a a child
that they can't take care of
um you know it that's should it just
shouldn't be uh it needs to be the
person the woman really needs to be able
to make her decision as to what she can
do when she can do it um you know until
the abortion is ingrained in the
Constitution this is just going to keep
going on and on with these bills uh this
morning's Bill trying to change the
Constitution I support that it really
that's the direction we need to be going
uh not individual little bills that keep
changing with every time the legislature
changes um I will not talk my wife is
going to talk so I won't talk her
specific abortion or her specific uh
pregnancy but you know leaving putting
in the in the bill you can only have an
abortion if the doctor says so uh we've
seen what's happened uh in Texas as an
example where someone needed a medical
induced abortion to save the woman's
life and she couldn't get it she was
struggling to get it she finally had to
leave the state of Texas to get it uh
when you suddenly start getting lawyers
involved in that you're going to be in
trouble and someone's you know you're
going to have women die or severely get
restricted because you put these bans in
there and restrictions in there that
they're afraid you know doctors are
afraid to do anything because they're
going to potentially lose their license
get fined get thrown in jail it's just
unacceptable so I'll leave it at that
thank you very much thank you questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you sir uh next uh
Aaron joerger
please thank you Mr
chairman got it right this time and
members of the committee I'm here to
voice my strong opposition to hp1 1248 I
strongly believe that decisions
regarding abortion should be solely left
to a pregnant person and her physician
this personal medical decision should
not be legislated I was fortunate to
have a healthy full-term pregnancy
however that was not guaranteed I had a
high risk for atopic
pregnancy I didn't know that I was
pregnant by 15 days and considering what
we've seen happen in other states with
very restrictive laws I may very well
have died if I if my pregnancy was a
topic even though the this particular
Bill allows exceptions for medical eerc
mercies we see doctors in other states
are delaying those procedures because
they're concern rightfully so for
criminal charges against them um we
can't allow this to happen in New
Hampshire instead I support cacr 23 to
ingrain abor abortion rights in New
Hampshire
Constitution I'd also like to challenge
the statement that pregnancy is only a
joy and not a burden or a disability
being someone who has actually gone
through pregnancy I can tell you that
even the easiest of pregnancies is a
great burden on a woman's body as well
as her time the time from work required
for medical appointments and for illness
often caused by pregnancy is Extreme I
was very fortunate that I had a job that
allowed me to take that time many women
don't they have to choose but between
pregnancy and having a job to support
themselves and their family so I will
say pregnancy can be both a joy and a
burden at the same
time I won't be here for the next
hearing for hp1 1541 but I'd like to
voice my opposition to that as well and
again urge you to support CAC
c23 lastly I'm going to leave with a
statement I believe that if men were the
ones that were able ble to get pregnant
we wouldn't be having this debate right
now thank you thank you very much
witness thank
you right and uh I'm going to call next
please bear with me I'm a little nervous
this is my first testimony uh good good
afternoon judicial Community my name is
Nicholas Patrick and I'm an independent
from Dublin New Hampshire I'm I'm here
to oppose House Bill 1248 I want to
first off by starting to poke some holes
in this bill this bill is to ban
abortion this has already been talked
about so I'll skip a little bit over
this but it should be called exactly
what it is a governmental Outreach on
individuals Reproductive Rights if you
look at Clause 2 and three of this bill
line 17 through 27 this bill does not
include instances of rape a woman should
not have the burden of raising a child
that was not her choice nor in any way
her
fault and I hope Representatives who
have impressed experience in the medical
field both administratively and handson
would believe and understand the
enormous burden that rape victims and
survivors already have to go through
physically mentally and financially and
having to raise a child entirely by
yourself isn't something the state
should be allowed or forced upon
anybody especially victims the state has
completely failed to protect and very
rarely bring Justice to secondly this
bill doesn't allow abortion for minors
many Republicans and even Democrats
stated earlier this week that a child is
incapable of making life-altering or
long-term decisions however forcing a
child to have a baby wholly violates
that
concept many of you have worked on
school boards and in
education and our parents and
grandparents of talented children and
grandchildren and understand that young
teenagers do not have the proper
maturity to properly raise a
child nor should they have no choice but
to take on such a monstrous and
tremendous task due to the
state
however most importantly it goes against
everything our state represents Live
Free or Die Give me liberty or give me
death that's something that I as well as
you have probably been taught from a
very young age a modotto that has guided
our state's politics and policies since
it's Inception and this ban isn't as
simple as if there should be abortion or
not abortion it goes so much deeper than
that it's an outof touch government
imposing its ideals and controlling the
people's
Liberties and and controlling 60% of
granite Staters according to 538 that
don't want to be restricted by the state
in this manner and at 70% according to
WM are and I've had friends who have
gotten abortions or the guys that were
the biological fathers and the biggest
lie that the opposition tells us is that
it's done without a heavy heart I'm here
telling you today that it absolutely is
however my friends weren't robbed of
their Liberties nor their
potential one is in law school one is
graduating Med and one is working as a
child
psychologist and I understand as a
political science student myself that we
have to pick a party in order to
maintain and get office however first
and foremost you made an oath to this
office you made an oath to us the
granite Staters and you made an oath to
this state and this state says it is not
your choice to make thank you and I'm
happy to answer any questions you may
have thank you very much sir questions
Witness
I'm sorry no seeing none thank you all
right that was the last uh card I have
on uh hb1 1248 is there anyone else here
who desires to testify on hb1
1248 all right uh seeing none with that
I'm going to close the hearing and I
think we're maybe a minute or two early
to start the hearing on the next bill so
we'll
take
can be looked at as sort of a compromise
and I hate to think about it that way
because I frankly wouldn't allow
abortions if I was given a choice but
what it does it
takes the 24 of 25 weeks that we have
and moves it up to 15
weeks and after that it's pretty much
the same except that knowing that
there's going to be some additional
chance of medical uh conditions you know
it it provides some add additional
Medical Care
uh the problem with abortions at 15
weeks 15 days 14 weeks whatever the the
time is isn't a problem of medical
issues that we should be trying to
handle it's it's a situation a natural
situation and it's it's not a a job for
uh Planned Parenthood it's not a job for
ACLU uh and it's it to me it's really
sad that we have to come together and
try to come up with some sort
of involved or or crazy solution to
Medical Care uh you whether it be a a
cicr which is really bad but
it it's not really a medical issue per
se it's an issue between a husband and a
wife and a decision to make to have a
baby and get some medical care if you
need it uh or if you know maybe you
believe it's necessary but let's get all
of us out of it let's get you and me out
of it and I hate to have to put up a
bill to say okay let's do it at 15 weeks
now which is versus the 25 24 weeks uh
you let's just get out of it thank you
right thank you uh questions for
representative Tes yes
representative
um if I may I have two questions one um
was it your intention by saying post
fertilization age of the
fetus um is would be 15 weeks are you
aware that that would actually mean 17
weeks excuse me I I can't that first
part I missed first part of your
question so the bill States the post
fertilization age of the fetus is at
least 15 weeks so are you aware that
that actually translates to 17
weeks I didn't didn't look at it that
way I didn't look at it that
witness seeing none thank you very much
representative testerman uh next I'm
going to call on representative uh
Christine Perez
please all right representative Perez
passes uh next I will call on
representative uh Mary uh hacken
Phillips
please
thank you a representative Mary hacken
Phillips for Grafton 12 I rise in
opposition of HB
1541 I'll limit my remarks to two
overall points given the compelling
testimony you will hear today from
providers and
Advocates first I'm here to relay an
important constituent story for your
consideration an OBGYN and Dartmouth
Hitchcock Medical Center physician and
professor of geel School of Medicine who
lives in my district and is licensed to
practice in both Vermont and in New
Hampshire has reported to me directly
that the attacks on his medical practice
in New Hampshire are pushing him to stop
offering his Provider Services in New
Hampshire and move his clinical practice
exclusively to
Vermont he feels that New Hampshire laws
regulating abortion care like this
arbitrary 15we ban in HB
1541 are an intrusion upon his medical
decision-making which follow national
standards of care and an intrusion upon
his professional
expertise this law if passed will send
another signal that New Hampshire does
not trust its OBGYN Physicians and does
not value their difficult and meaningful
work passage of this bill would take
away vital access to abortion procedures
that are a vital part of this doctor's
work passage will cement the message
that New Hampshire is not serious
about giving providers all the tools
they need to best serve their patients
this bill will be another depressing
moral defeat in the many attacks upon
the profession causing our state's
OBGYNs to lose further confidence in New
Hampshire's legislators for putting
politics ahead of people in their
healthcare for these reasons I hope you
will oppose this
bill secondly I'm here on behalf of my
provider constituents and the maternally
reproductive age individuals of my
district to express my deep
disappointment that we even need to
expend this much Collective energy and
these resources to entertain a bill that
further restricts reproductive health
care for women without
acknowledging without naming the true
discrimination that pregnant individuals
in New Hampshire are facing due to these
ongoing political attacks the mere fact
that we're not discussing the efficacy
and the wisdom of restricting male
reproductive Healthcare procedures when
a man is 50% of the cause of all
pregnancies demonstrates the true
discrimination against an injustice
thrust upon New Hampshire's
demonstrates first of all this is the
point that really makes me fill with
rage attacks on women's health care but
not men's healthare is blatant
discrimination based on race excuse me
sex blatant discrimination based on sex
and it is a substantial government
interference of medical privacy but even
though I'm filled with this rage about
these attacks on my constituent
providers and potentially my own body is
that I'm dedicated to climbing every
proverbial Mountain to defeat bills like
hb1 1541 to ensure access to safe and
effective reproductive Health Care
procedures and for these Reasons I'm
asking the committee to please
bipartisan vote uh to please vote
bipartison Le to defeat hb1 1541 please
vote or in expedient to legislate thank
you questions for questions for this
witness yes representative Paige thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question um I share your uh frustration
that the legislator is in the middle of
this uh personal issue and I think if I
heard correctly when the bill was
introduced there was an expression that
the um intent of the bill may have been
to um remove the government from from
this this decision-making process and
keep it within
the the mom and family and
provider with that in mind would cacr 23
be a better vehicle to that goal than
this
bill um thank you for your question
representative I think it's really an
important question to be asking uh
especially amongst yourselves as members
of the committee who will ultimately
decide the fate of both of these bills
um of course an affirmative
um an affirmative display or
codification of women's right pregnant
people's right to reproductive Freedom
um has a more positive connotation for
sure um and it will hold a lot more
protections affirmatively it will fill
the void that is currently um in New
Hampshire law you know and missing from
our books
um you know proposing statutory
arbitrary weak band on women's
reproductive Health um will bring a lot
of negative connotation for a lot of
people who are affected personally by
that um that codification so you know
whether we're talking about providers
being taken away tools that they need to
do their job or we're talking about you
know families and pregnant people who
are having those decisions taken away
from them based on some arbitrary weak
designation so um I think that's an
important question I think um ultimately
I think many of us believe that you know
the natural progression of where we are
discussing these bills from year to year
is going to lead us to ultimately a
constitutional question of whether or
not this should be affirmatively written
and protected in our state's most you
know highest law um but I think you know
given the political will and the makeup
of the bodies that are before us at this
time in our Chambers we have to be
prepared for any step that we can take
affirmatively towards the direction of
protecting Women's Healthcare thanks
other questions for this witness
representative Perez thank you for
taking my question would you feel better
if it
said if the wording went that um it was
only that they tried to save the
baby if it was not a baby that was born
with a uh lifethreatening fetal anomaly
that type of thing so thank you
representative for the question um and I
just reject the premise um again going
back to my remarks the mere fact that
we're not discussing limiting other
people's Healthcare but we're limiting
women's healthare is the issue that I'm
most upset about and that you know any
phonetic changes that you may determine
is more pable for your party to pass is
not something that I'm willing to
entertain anyway so we are not even
coming close to
that other yes representative
trip thank you for asking answering my
question uh it appears to me that the
conditions within this bill are only
effective after 15 weeks do you read it
that
way I'm
sorry I said it appears to me that the
conditions within this bill are only in
a effect after
a a gestation period of 15 weeks do you
read it that way thank you for the
question I have I don't have the
language in front of me here so I
couldn't tell you an answer off the top
of my head but I'm happy to dig in and
report back to you all right well thank
you other questions for this
witness see none I guess I just had one
question I noticed you you made the
point about the discrimination against
women uh that you know that you think
this would impose and and you know at
least personally you might be right I
guess I wonder on the other side of that
um since it is the law that it's the
woman's Choice whether to have an
abortion or not would you agree that
there that if the woman decides to have
an abortion over the objection of the
father that the woman should be solely
responsible for support of the child and
should not be able to impo impose a
support obligation on the man so thank
you representative for the question I
believe those questions are outside the
scope of the actual matter before us St
at hand so I'm going to go ahead and
decline to respond given that you know
that's not what we're discussing and
that's not you know the substance of the
bill at hand today thank you right any
other questions for this
you thank you Mr chair and committee
thanks again to John soles grafting
18 District
18 I'm not going to rehash everything
again with you know it's the same thing
just a different Bill uh it's not quite
the same thing let's put that way but I
do want to point out a couple more
things and I heard one thing said today
about reproduction or Reproductive
Rights Reproductive Rights Reproductive
Rights you ever looked up the term what
reproductive right or reproduction means
means to reproduce all right I mean
we're not talking about reproducing
we're talking about killing
terminating all right that's what we're
truly talking about all right 15 days 15
weeks putting in a cacr you're talking
about killing you're not talking about
reproducing or Reproductive Rights I
mean this is how they go and change the
terms of the words and stuff like that
and it shouldn't
happen one other note I'm going to point
out here is from the American
Association of pro-life Obstetricians
and
gynecologists abortion is not Health
Care
all right in it it's being used for
healthc care it's you know I'm going to
give you the document you can look up
all the facts for yourself 95% of the
healthcare abortion exploits the woman
and kills an innocent pre-born
life when caring for a pregnant woman
Physicians are caring for two distinct
patients the woman and The Unborn
Child I think that's enough said I mean
at this point here we know we might
Dicker over when life starts but I I can
I like to say I can prove it but
scientifically they have proved it I
don't have to prove it you know
immediately from day one the cells not
the blob it's not a blob it's not a
growth it's not a tumor the cells start
to divide and the cells are already
known the
xxxy what they are at that moment this
is something that's just not made up all
right this is scientifically so we're
not talking about reproduction we're
talking about killing all right
destroying terminating abortion that's
what we're talking about thank you all
right questions for this
witness see none thank you very much sir
please good afternoon members of the
committee um I will be brief I know has
been a long day my name is Kayla
Montgomery I'm the vice president of
public affairs for Planned Parenthood of
Northern New England and Planned
Parenthood New Hampshire action fund we
are here in opposition today to House
Bill
1541 this bill is a government overreach
into the practice of safe legal Medical
Care in New Hampshire and we POS it this
bill would prevent patients from
accessing abortion care from trusted
providers like Planned Parenthood after
15 weeks abortion is safe at every stage
of pregnancy with absolutely no
justification this bill would prohibit
highly qualified and trained providers
like those at Planned Parenthood of
Northern New England from offering care
after 15 weeks now patients they seek
this care uh at the stage of pregnancy
for a variety of reasons including
because they have been forced to delay
care in order to travel from ban States
this bill disregards the best interest
of patients by further limiting
availability of this time sensitive care
and creating even more barriers for
pregnant people and their
families additionally this bill impacts
the way hospitals deliver their Care by
interfering with standard medical
practice and imposing burdens on
unnecessary mandates any health care
provider will tell you every pregnancy
is different and circumstances can
change quickly throughout a pregnancy a
person's health and their well-being not
political interference should guide
important medical decisions and I also
want to note that this bill lacks
compassion for grieving families I'm not
going to get into that because you this
committee heard a similar Bill like this
just last year and this committee um
voted to itl that bill so just in uh in
closing this bill does nothing to
protect Granite Staters health or safety
and we appr uh we uh urge you to oppose
this bill happy to take questions
witness uh yes representative peret
thank you for taking my questions last
year in speaking to you um you stated to
me that Planned Parenthood did not do
abortions over 15 weeks and that has now
increased I believe to 21 weeks I have a
couple questions where did you send
people to have abortions after where did
you refer people to have abortions after
weeks sure so um I appreciate the uh
question and I appreciate the question
because it gives me an opportunity to
explain this committee what has really
changed on the ground in the last year
so as this committee knows 18 months ago
roie Wade fell that um created chaos in
this country so throughout the last 18
months we've seen bans in different
states right now as of today we're at I
think 21 states have banned abortion a
year ago uh February 16th I believe it
was I stood before this committee and I
said that in Manchester we perform
abortions to 15 weeks and that was true
at the time in the year we have seen
more patients coming from out of state
we're seeing patients from across this
country who are coming from band States
in order to get the care that they need
we have been listening to patients we
have been hearing them and what we know
is that they have delays in care because
it takes them time to get to us so we
have been able to expand access to care
at Planned Parenthood over the last year
in two ways the first is that we have
added medication abortion at a third
site in New Hampshire in Dairy so now we
do medication abortion at three out of
four of our health centers and at the
Manchester Health Center we did um move
to 18 weeks um and we did that not
overnight but in the last
year do you have a followup yes my
question
was where do you refer or where did you
refer patients
to if if you were not performing them
after 15
weeks sure so like I said now we now go
to 18 weeks but we were referring people
to other states or to Dartmouth or um
other uh providers that perform abortion
later in
pregnancy okay I called every clinic in
the state of New Hampshire and none of
them do it over 15 weeks six days so it
must have been to Dartmouth then am I am
I well you know know I represent PL
Parenthood and I'm telling you that we
you know within the last year we started
going to 18 weeks one more quick
question yep is there a reason why you
don't perform them to 24 weeks since
that's what everybody seems yeah I mean
I so of course I'll remind this
committee that abortion is safe and
legal to 24 weeks um and uh it is well
known it is a well-known fact that
abortion is uh perfectly safe throughout
the second trimester at outpatient um
facilities like Planned Parenthood is we
just aren't equipped to go to 24
weeks uh it is legal but it is just U
more training more staff support and
things like that so that's where we
that's where we're at right now
representative cab I believe you have a
question any other questions for
this yes representative
sted thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I think I heard you
say that there was an increase of uh
patients coming from out of state for
abortions and the New Hampshire that's
correct sound is very difficult in here
um I'd be curious to know what
percentage of total abortions are those
out of Staters representative in in your
uh
operations thank you for that question
um I don't have the numbers off the top
of my head of course but this is
something that we are seeing everywhere
in all states where abortion is still
safe and legal we are seeing a real
increase of patients from out of state
in Northern New England we are not
seeing patients from out of state in the
same way that states who are surrounded
by other ban States might see so two
examples of states that see a lot of
people from out of state would be
Colorado and Illinois because they have
ban states around them here in Northern
New England we of course do see patients
from out of state people come to New
Hampshire for a variety of reasons um
sometimes it's because they have family
here and they want to be surrounded by a
support network when they come here so I
would say the numbers are probably under
10% of people who are coming from out of
state but the reason that they're coming
um is because they've been pushed out of
their home state for care and that
delays care when politicians ban
pregnancy it delays the care for people
thank you followup yes yes please I've
also heard that most abortions uh are
done in the first
trimester much fewer in the second Y and
much much fewer in the
third
um
what what percentage of numbers in in
the second trimester and would it make a
difference if it were 17 or 18 weeks in
the bill instead of
15 to answer the last question first I
would say uh we don't support abortion
banss period um yes abortion uh the
first part of your question yes the vast
majority of abortions happen in the
first trimester I believe the number is
93% um medication abortion is
um uh an option for people to end a
pregnancy early in pregnancy it's up to
11 weeks um nationally that number is
about 50% of people who choose
medication abortion over a procedural
abortion a PL Parenthood in Northern New
England that number is actually much
higher it's actually
72% so the vast majority of abortion is
happening earlier but there's many
reasons that someone might need an
abortion later in pregnancy or into the
second trimester for a variety of
reasons as I discussed
other questions for this
witness so I just I guess I just had one
question if I'm understanding correctly
what what or am I understanding
correctly that there's been because of
of of uh the laws that have changed
since roie Wade was overruled and did I
understand correctly you were saying
that there has been sort of an increase
in the call for uh abortion services in
certainly there's people in New
Hampshire who also need abortion after
15 weeks we know that um but in addition
we are seeing people from other states
who are coming in okay and and and I
take it you've been able to accommodate
that yes right uh is there any
inconsistency between that what you've
just told us and this expressed fear of
people who have testified earlier that
uh uh you know we're losing our ability
to uh to satisfy the needs of women
because of these laws apparently you've
been able to actually provide increased
Services is that correct yeah I would
say that the the fear is that this is
this is a really chaotic landscape
because every day I mean all of you have
read the headlines every day there's
something new out there there's
something confusing some things before
The Supreme Court we now have two
abortion cases before The Supreme Court
that will come out in June so I think
the confusion is that no one's really
sure and um you know having something
proactive on the books at Constitution
Amendment would help assure people of
that and so right now people just it's
confusing for people and when they hear
there's a 15-day or a 15we ban it's just
it's frankly confusing thank you uh
other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
uh Courtney uh uh
breed I think that's right Reed I'm
sorry Courtney Reed
sorry thank you chair I'll try to get
better about my handwriting next time I
have to fill out a pink card um thank
you all for listening to my testimony uh
I am here with the ACLU New Hampshire in
opposition to HB
1541 and that this bill would prevent
doctors from exercising their best
medical judgment when providing
abortions after 15 weeks of gestation
moreover the bill would impose harmful
restrictions on abortion care in New
Hampshire that are neither warranted nor
rooted in medical
accuracy the requirement of abortions
after 15 weeks to take place in hospital
settings as well as having a second
physician on hand single out abortion to
burdensome regulations that are not
reflected in other areas of Medical
Practice
practice further the Bill's requirement
um would make it so Physicians are bound
to what politicians are inserting that
they do rather than their training and
expertise and we know that Physicians
are also Bound by medical ethics and
that infanticide is already IL legal at
the federal level yet this bill makes it
more difficult for them to exercise
their appropriate judgment in standards
of care and Compassionate Care
during pregnancies or when people are
seeking legal abortions in New
Hampshire moreover I just want to
underline that the bills uh subjecting
of providers to New Hampshire state laws
governing homicide manslaughter and
civil liability for wrongful death
medical
malpractice will cause uh Physicians out
of an abundance of caution for fear of
these criminal penalties to limit care
to pregnant people um they won't be able
to exercise their medical judgment
freely um because these criminal
liabilities will cause them to act in a
restraint way or for uh example uh with
the exceptions in the bill for pregnant
individuals to demonstrate um clear
illness to an undefined
point uh and lastly I just wanted to
note that um legislation like this has
shown time and time again to be
unpopular with voters and so I would
urge that the committee vote um against
this bill and siding with individual
freedom and the right to privacy um
rather than inserting themselves in what
should be private and independent
Healthcare decisions thank you and I'm
happy to take questions thank you
witness yes representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my
question does New Hampshire
limit
who can have an abortion in New
Hampshire does New Hampshire limit who
has the right to an abortion what female
has a right to the
abortion in New Hampshire and the reason
why I asked is that in your testimony
here that you have given out I was a
little taken back
um that these burdens will
disproportionately fall on women of
colors who struggling to make ends young
people immigrants people with
disabilities and LGBT communities
moreover abortion banss which we don't
have an abortion ban are also also
anticipated to disproportionately
produce negative health comes Health
outcomes for the bipac communities
research finds abortion is significantly
safer than pregnancy for black and IND
ous
people I was not under the impression
that there was anything in the New
Hampshire laws that restricted abortion
to anybody based on their ethnic
background their um their Identity or
anything but yet you're saying
that you're implying in this
testimony that
um
that we are and I just didn't know that
that thank you for your question
representative um to start off with that
I think that a lot of Reproductive
Rights Advocates would assert that
abortion rights is a racial justice
issue what is a racial justice issue
when bans happen we see desparate Health
consequences fall on communities that
are black and brown and that's been
demonstrated through numerous research
articles that I I cite in my um written
hand out to you all for example um the
disparities um the racial disparities in
maternal mortality rates that would
happen um should there be an allout ban
in the United States um which is why
it's so important that the committee
vote decisively against this bill um as
to not exacerbate um racialized Health
inequality that we're seeing across the
country and and moreover there's a lot
of research that cites that black and
brown communities in healthcare spaces
are uh more likely to be policed than
wealthy white patients um I believe the
study that I cited was coming from the
uh Sunni School of Law human rights
clinic in addition with a few other
co-authors and I would love to pull out
some of the specic specific findings and
concerns there that um had motivated um
my inclusion of that into my testimony
thank
you yes thank you but we're talking
about New Hampshire and this was all put
under the cacr
23 offering rights my question was I do
not believe if no matter who I am what
color I am what my ethnic background is
or what my identity is if I walked into
a Planned Parenthood they are going to
to tell me because of any of those
things here in New Hampshire I cannot
have an
abortion that's not happening here is
that
correct that's correct there's nothing
in state law that excludes uh the right
to an abortion depending on someone's
race or
background other question yes uh
representative P quick question thanks
for taking thanks Mr chair thanks for
taking my question is it possible
possible uh misre that when the
legislature passes a law it could not
intentionally impact a particular group
um in a certain way but might
desparately impact a group just based on
that uh group's access to health care or
to Quality education or whatnot is it
possible that that's is that possible
thank you for your question
representative and that's exactly what I
was hoping to speak to in my response to
the last question and should New
Hampshire follow along um you know in
other states in the wrong direction I
think we are worried that this could
make Health disparities at the national
level um even broader thank
you other questions for this witness so
I guess I just have one on you're
talking about disparate impact and I
guess I'm wondering is um if the if the
test that we rely on should be disparate
impact I wonder if you could tell me any
government regulation that that would
not have a disparate impact in the way
you're talking about I mean wouldn't
that be wouldn't it be that almost
almost any government regulation of some
kind or other would have a disparate
impact on the people that you're talking
about yeah I think that's right that a
lot of legislation that passes has a
latent effect that would affect racial
inequality but I do know that what we're
seeing nationally is that when
legislation like this is passed it has a
negative effect that exacerbates
existing Public Health inequalities and
so passing this bill would only move
Health inequality across racialized
lines in the wrong
direction all right other questions Mr
CH yes represent lenzo thank you for
taking my
question I'm looking at the bill and one
of the things that stands out to me is
that the procedure is listed in
the in the um Bill requires two
positions attending the um the abortion
I was wondering how that would impact um
you know Health
Care in the shortage of doctors and and
New
Hampshire thank you so much for your
question representative um I have a
better understanding of how the effect
of a required hospital um presence would
FF the bill and I know that that would
make it extremely hard or impossible for
clinics in New Hampshire to offer these
services to patients but I would love to
um perhaps have that question be asked
to um a direct provider of abortion
thank you thank you other questions for
this
winess seeing none thank you very much
please
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is Janelle Hopson
I am the executive director of the
equality Health Center which is right
here in conquer and I want to thank you
for the opportunity to provide testimony
and opposition of HB
1541 for 50 years the equality Health
Center has provided compassionate
quality healthc care to all genders and
sexualities we are the longest serving
abortion provider in the state our
professionally trained and credentialed
medical staff excuse me are Dartmouth
Affiliated and provide safe expert and
effective outpatient services which do
not require more expensive inpatient
care every poll confirms that New
Hampshire residents support safe legal
accessible Reproductive Rights doctors
nurses attest that politics have no
place in the proc procedure room it is
the belief of the equality Health Center
that government overreach such as HB
1541 intrudes and singles out clinics
which provide abortion
Services it communicates a mistrust of
and a lack of support for
facilities that patients actively seek
for their appropriate Health
Care decisions about private
reproductive healthc care belong to a
patient
in consultation with their doctor and
not with the legislature which should be
which should only be concerned with the
protection of our citizens rights to
receive comprehensive
Services I urge you to vote in expedient
to legislate on HB 1541 I want to thank
you for your time I will not be taking
any questions and I will submit written
testimony later today thank you thank
you uh Heather stock well please I I
pardon I already SP oh you already all
right okay okay fine um Emily uh Z
zazano
please good afternoon chairin and
honorable committee members it is good
to see you again my name is Emily Zano
and I ask you to oppose hb1
1541 this bill will interfere with
compassionate care and force medical
interventions that will not affect
survival I am a doctor a mother of two
living children and as I shared earlier
I am a woman who had two abortions due
to complications during pregnancy with
twins the first was due to uterine
rupture the second abortion was due to a
high risk of hemorrhage again and
miscarriage before viability born too
early for medical interventions to save
her
life if it had been different and she
would was born before viability then let
me hold her let me love her let her feel
my warmth and hear my voice let her
father touch her skin and stroke her
hair he never got to feel her kick from
the womb like I did do not force her
into an incubator and medical procedures
with lines and tubes and
scalpel ventilators and monitors and
sterile gloves let her time be with us
her family and let us decide how that
time is spent let us build memories of
loving her not watching her
suffer families in complex unexpected
and often heartbreaking situations like
options we should be able to make
difficult decisions with our doctors
including comfort care for babies who
will not survive regardless of medical
interventions as a mom
this needs to be allowed this needs to
be legal this is not an appropriate
place for political interference these
are impossible decisions to be made by
parents medical experts the people in
that room with all due respect this is
not a decision for the people in a
legislative committee room as a doctor I
urge you do not force doctors to deny
fam's Compassionate Care don't threaten
them with years of imprisonment to do
something that goes against their best
medical judgment against all the facts
in front of them I ask you to consider
the hypocritic oath which implores first
Do no harm a state mandate for medical
interventions that will not change
survival outcomes is the definition of
harm it denies families the opportunity
to hold their babies before they pass
and piles up unnecessary expensive
medical bills for futile
care there are systems in place that
support families in these unimaginable
heartbreaking situations do not create a
system that makes this terrible time
worse this bill does not give room for
paliative
care I'd also like to remind this
committee that a similar bill was before
you just last year HB 346 and this
committee voted to defeat that bill by a
vote of 18 to1 because the reality is
that no law can be written to thread the
needle of these complex situations
please reject HB 1541 thank you thank
you questions for this word
representative
K thank you Mr chairman and thank you Dr
Zano for taking my question I appreciate
it I wanted to ask you spoke a lot to
the line in the bill that's regarding
the immediate care for a child born
alive as a result of the
abortion and since this would be um
until viability which is now known would
you agree is at 24 weeks
um would this mean that any baby that
was born before that perhaps for reasons
that they do have anomalies that are
incompatible with life that they would
need to immediately be provided life
sustaining care that could potentially
only prolong their life for hours or
days as opposed to being in the arms of
time so I think I understand your
question but I might have confused it in
my head so this bill is confusing and
conflating viability with 15 weeks that
is months apart in time and not
medically
accurate um viability is a moving Target
as Medical Care
advances and suggesting that you can
interpose 15 weeks in viability is
simply incorrect um I think there was a
part of your question question regarding
could you just repeat that part yeah so
I was saying that wouldn't you agree
that as of right now viability is
accepted to be at 24 weeks and so as a
result this bill although it says 15
weeks actually post uh fertilization so
technically VI 17 weeks so from 17 weeks
until 23 weeks and 6 days that these
babies would be required to be taken
from their parents and provided like uh
measures to prolong their life that even
though they're not
I do agree I think that it would take
the opportunity for families
to love their children and grieve their
loss and instead separate them put these
fetuses
in sterile and pain painful and
dangerous
positions are very unlikely to survive
them
[Music]
creating situations that we can't
understand understand as adults that
we're putting
small fetus baby it's a strange space
it's a nonviable pregnancy that was
birthed right
um
I through my training worked in NICU I
trained with OBGYNs
I I have seen what a lot of these
infants have gone through
and there is
a amazing care that can happen and still
have tragic outcomes so I don't think we
should force that on
anyone thank you questions for this
goodness seeing none thank you very much
please hello again um Maris stoland
OBGYN um I had a nice little speech
prepared Dr Zano told basically every
point that I was going to make um so I'm
not going to repeat those um I think
members um uh of the Judiciary Committee
also probably remember me from last year
because I also spoke about this topic um
when the previous um House Bill uh with
similar language was introduced um this
bill has some very Troublesome language
that I think Dr Zano
really hit on the points of um these
scenarios where we have fetuses between
this gray area um you know around what
we call Parry viability viability is a
moving Target it depends on lots of
different situations but the bottom line
is that these situations are are tragic
when they come up and um the language in
this bill is basically taking those
tragic situations taking them out of the
hands of healthc care providers and
essentially
forcing um the presence of an
unnecessary second physician which
affects Staffing ratios and other
aspects of the hospital it also dictates
that the ICU needs to be available which
is not a finite resource and um not
something that should be used as less
necessary and it's demanding that those
resources be available for a situation
that is futile um we do not have the
capability to resuscitate a fetus at
these gestational ages um and really the
word um that for me it brings up is
traumatic these situations are doing
what this bill would suggest would be
absolutely traumatic it would be
traumatic for the fetus it would be
traumatic for parents it would be
traumatic for healthc Care staff it
would be traumatic for um nurses it
would be traumatic for the people who
clean the rooms afterwards all of this
is against every fiber of what we learn
in medicine to do no harm to submit
these um infants and these families to
procedures that are completely
unnecessary and at the same time to
waste precious Health Care Resources in
a time when we don't have enough
resources to do what we're trying to do
as it is it's appalling I I I can't read
this bill without getting upset I
strongly oppose this bill and I urge you
also to do so thank thank you questions
for this
witness yes representative
tur yeah thanks for taking my question
uh my understanding is that that
hospitals in the state that perform um
deliveries
have policies in place about when they
will or will not um except transfers for
example for premature um uh labor or um
perform life saving you know heroic
Measures Etc on on um she are can you
speak to that a little bit in terms of
what how what those policies are and how
they would interact with a a bill like
this uh sure I just redirect me if I'm
not answering the question that you'd
like to have answered um depending on
the gestational age and and I'll just
put a caveat that medical science is
constantly changing we are constantly
evaluating the literature we are
constantly looking at research and and
trying to make the best decisions based
on new information so so these things
sometimes change over time and you know
there there are Trends you know some
actual parts of the country have the
technical capabilities to um you know
potentially have better outcomes at at
lower gestational ages than other parts
of the country all of this is is um you
know a little variable depending on
where you are and you know where we are
in time and our understanding of of
Medical Science um in terms of you know
the resources to deal with different
situations um essentially the higher the
gestational age um in that per viable
window the more potential chance there
is um to resuscitate but the chances um
of of success are still exceedingly low
um those chances of success are much
much lower at facilities that don't have
the same resources but before a certain
gestational age it doesn't matter where
you are we just don't have the
capability to to do anything to help and
so you know I think it is a phenomenon
that sometimes happens where let's say
I'll give you a scenario let's say um
someone comes in at um 18 weeks and has
um premature rupture of their membranes
meaning they broke their water um at 18
weeks which
essentially we can't do anything about
we can't unbreak the water we can't
reform it we you know at that point um
you know there's basically nothing that
we can do except to try to prevent that
patient from becoming septic um meaning
having a an overwhelming bacterial
infection um that could kill the patient
um and so in those situations
um there there is no real benefit to
transferring or using healthc Care
Resources like an ambulance a Life
Flight um ICU resources different
doctors Specialists that's a waste of
those resources for a situation that
really needs to be
handled at the initial place where it
presents because there is unfortunately
I wish there were but there is no hope
for resuscitating an 18we fetus and the
bottom line is is that other facilities
are equipped to be able to help that
patient in a much more efficient and
expedient
manner does that answer your
question believe it does thanks thank
you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Barry
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Barry I'm the vice president of policy
at new Futures as many of you know we're
a nonprofit Health policy and advocacy
organization we've been working for more
than 25 years to increase access to
quality affordable health care and to
improve health equity in our state I
don't want to repeat too much of what's
been said this afternoon but I do want
to stress new future strong opposition
to both this bill and hb1 1248 which you
heard earlier this afternoon simply put
reproductive care including abortion is
a critical part of Health Care and
access to abortion has vital
implications on the health and wellness
of women families and children across
our state data shows that women who do
not have sufficient access to abortion
when they need it are more likely to
struggle physically and financially
they're more likely to experience
life-threatening Health complications
including a IIA and postpartum
Hemorrhage as well as other health
conditions like chronic migraines joint
pain and just and gestational
hypertension both women and children are
who are born as a result of abortion
denial are more likely to live below the
federal poverty level and do not have
the money they need to cover basic
living expenses like food housing and
transportation and some to adopt further
abortion bans whether they 15 weeks as
proposed in this bill or 15 days as
proposed in NH hb1
1248 would have severe impact acts on
the physical and Financial Health of
women and children that both they and we
as a state will be paying for throughout
their lifetimes for these reasons we ask
you to oppose both this bill 1541 and
House Bill 1248 and vote itl thank you
and I'm happy to take questions
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you uh Beverly
uh press you're still having a hard time
with my last name it's licky it's polish
and uh my my uh testimony has been
already I mean I was curious of the way
the language of the of the way the bill
was written with the 15 weeks I was
curious as to how prepared our uh you
know medical people were to to
resuscitate uh potential babies at 15
weeks I mean I was like how is that
going to happen so this person who
testified did a wonderful job and I've
been very honored to be here I haven't
addressed the committee properly it's
the first time I've ever been here but
um I didn't even know that this was
happening today until I was given a tips
and I I've learned a lot today and um I
hope that you you know you'll listen to
some of that testimony that they heard
prior because this bill to me does not
make any sense and I'm just a lay person
you know I'm not a doctor or legislature
or anybody I'm just somebody who's
interested in the future of you know
future generations and their ability to
access what I had access to uh in the
1980s so thank you thank you very much
any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you um I don't
have any other pink cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
1541 I think we are a Jour thank you all
for
coming